at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O hey it's us again yeah don't you guys
ever get sick of watching us like
gapping about [__] that's amazing it's
gonna be it's gonna be a good show today
this is gonna be about
dragons yeah we're going to talk about
where these ideas came from you know was
it really dinosaurs what what what what
what spurred this [__] on about dragons
it's not as simple as you think it is
all right I love comparative mythology
right and I think the reason cuz I think
we got off on this on some like maybe on
the Sidetrack show or something like
that cuz I was talking about always been
fascinated by dragons in particular
because pretty much every culture around
the world has Dragon Stories oh thank
you very much thank you oh so yeah
murder Hornet came back and joined the
joined the uh channel the membership
thing that YouTube has yep which is
called flash bulbs yeah it's called
flash bulbs there's only one tier it's
called flashl it's kind of like a
patreon thing you know but it's not
patreon it's YouTube but it's the same
kind of thing membership and you also
get to vote on uh topics and stuff like
that just like the patreon members yeah
this got voted on yeah so this was the
thing that got voted on and like I said
I think we were talking about before
because I've always been fascinated by
cuz like look we were we were talking
about this and we were talking about
this this morning we were kind of
discussing the show and I said I feel
like most cultures around the world also
have like sasquatchy kind of myths too
but that doesn't seem quite as weird
because that's just like a big hairy
dude right and that's just like a person
but big and furry yeah whereas dragons
that's something quite specific yeah a
modern person would say well [__] they
just talking about dinosaurs and no
maybe not yeah and they're probably not
talking about alligators either so we're
going to get down to it yeah but it's
like really interesting like the
similarities and the differences I have
my own theories about maybe where the
stories came from but um is a chines
Dragon the same as a European Dragon
we're going to get into that that's what
I mean it's like yeah they're different
which we'll get into but they have a lot
of similarities too like I said a dragon
is something very specific and I feel
like even though there are different
iterations of it in different cultures
around the world that's still
recognizably a dragon like you could
show somebody like a Chinese dragon that
had never seen one and they'd be like oh
that's a dragon it still looks like a
dragon yeah the Aztec had dragons yeah
and we're going to talk about that too
like everybody does yeah and that's
like that's crazy to me yeah and it's
like well I mean not crazy but it's just
like interesting I think how this happen
was this some kind of convergent
evolution in the mind just something
people would come up with was there uh
was there widespread cultural exchange
that we're not really aware of like you
know maybe they they travel more than we
think that they did we're going to get
down into that yeah talk about that I'm
well I don't know if I want to
necessarily spoil my what my theory is
no we'll talk about it later
but well yeah what I kind of wanted to
do the way I had it set up and you guys
when I started delving into this I've
been working on this for almost like two
days straight right like trying to
trying to winnow this down because
Dragon mythology is vast um like I said
pretty much every culture around the
world has stories about dragons and so
kind of pairing it down to just like the
real interesting [__] or whatever it's
like so I had to cut a lot of stuff out
you know what I mean so just know that
the stuff that I'm talking about there's
like Millions more stories you know what
I mean I just kind of stuck to some of
the better known ones and then just
stuff that I found personally
interesting and even then this this show
might still be [__] 4 hours long I'm
not really we try to keep it we're
trying to we'll try to keep it like I
don't want to get too far into the
because I'm going to say that um and I'm
just going to apologize for this in
advance because we're talking about you
know a lot of Chinese mythology we're
talking about Norse mythology um you
know Aztec mythology stuff like that um
I'm like my pronunciation of [__] is
going to be um not good I'm just going
to tell you that right now and um
because I'm looking at some of the names
of some of the dragons like from some
I'm just like there is just no [__]
way that I'm going to know how to
pronounce that yeah I'll do my best but
you know the the more I drink the less
it's G to or or the more I drink the
less I'm going to care so I might just
like you know what I mean I might do
better who
knows but yeah so what I what I was kind
of planning on doing is kind of going
around the world almost like
chronologically but not quite kind of I
thought you going to say sexually going
around the world sexually going around
the world sexually that was a term you
know that's oldfashioned term going
around the world okay all right when
people say they going around the world
now that means you're going to Epcot and
you're drink
just going all the drinking Boo at all
the which my brother loves to do that's
one of his favorite things but um but
yeah because sex around the world did
you have you done that time no no well
probably I did but didn't think of it as
think of it like that I was going to say
yeah you've been a lot of places so
yeah Tammy said Jenny your pronunciation
is going to be a hell of a lot better
than any of ours well I don't know if
I'd go that far but um like I said I've
seen seen some of the words and I'm just
like oh that's that's going to be a
rough one but we'll see how it goes
we'll see how it goes but yeah so yeah
so we wanted to kind of like go around
the world maybe chronologically roughly
in time and um then at the end I kind of
want to go into all the theories that
people have about why all of these
cultures have such similar stories even
though they supposedly didn't interact
with one another like when these stories
came from cuz dragon stories are
old way old you know what I mean like
pre like predating writing predating all
of that yeah it's strange that the
Egyptians didn't have it though they do
they did they do have AP they're going
to say apep was apep and there were
there were a couple of other ones too
massive serpents I was thinking would
apep be a dragon he is okay and there's
a couple other ones too like yeah I have
that in my
so they did have a dragon yeah they did
then that would be kind of like the
midgard serpent that's we got we got
that one too apep would be the midgard
serpent wouldn't it kind of sort of well
actually the Egyptians I can't remember
what its name is but it's in my notes
they the Egyptians actually have one
that's more like the
midgard yeah the midgard right right
right
okay interestingly I stumbled across
this documentary on YouTube
today which was actually kind of cool it
was you remember that you remember when
the Discovery Channel did that like
mermaid mockumentary oh yeah my dad got
fooled by I know this was kind of like
that but it was much better and it was
about dragons it was acting as though
there was a
paleontologist who like they found this
cave where these um where a dragon
essentially had been preserved and like
it went into um them being like this
can't be a [__] dragon and then like
they but so they went at they came at it
from like a scientific point of view and
then they had like a um like a um uh
reenactments of like the dragon like
fighting a T-Rex and stuff like that it
was actually pretty cool I it was
British or like the guy that was that
did the narration was British um but it
was actually pretty fun and I was just
kind of like this is actually kind of
cool and like it kind of taught you
science at the same time but obviously
it was you know it's pretending like
dragons are real but they were
completely like serious about it so I
don't I can't remember what it's called
but I thought it was like kind of cool
but it was a good idea yeah Leviathan
too yeah we're going to talk about that
also but uh yeah Ben says not mythology
history yeah um and like I said we'll
get into it toward the end but I mean
people could
be I I don't think they're talking about
a real
animal but they could be exaggerating a
real animal
or
several animals or something right where
did they get this idea what we get down
to and like that's what's always like
fascinating me about this because it
seems like it's one of the few I don't
know if that's true because there's a
lot of real common mythologies that kind
of span cultures you know what I mean
werewolves that too yeah like yeah like
human Transformations that aren't real
it seems to be Roman so maybe it's not
so much a case of
you know somebody coming up with the
story and then like you know everybody
kind of being like Oh it's good doing
their own version of it but it's like
maybe human brains just naturally go
along these particular tracks and one of
them happens to be Dron like a dragon
thing you know what I mean although the
words that they use to describe early
dragons doesn't mean Dragon not
literally a lot of times it means
serpent that's so that's the thing we're
talking about yeah what the [__] are
they talking
about
snakes
yeah some shit's called translates to
worm but they mean wyvern or snake yeah
what they mean
serpent yeah I mean that's literally
where the word comes from which I'm
going to get into in a second right but
yeah and we should note too that and I
think most people know this that know
anything about dragons but the Western
conception of the Dragon is different
than the Eastern conception of the
Dragon gener not always it's a different
character um but and and there are some
Eastern stories that are closer to the
Western ones which kind of uh lends
evidence to the theory that I'm kind of
uh that I think is the case but
generally in the western tradition
dragons are usually seen as like
Monsters something to be defeated like
the devil
yeah in the Bible yes but like I said
it's much older than that yeah it's much
older than that but they're coming back
to Tiamat yeah and [__] yeah we're
going to talk about thato the cosmic
dragon that Marduk Slade is what they're
talking about back in back in [__]
that's Babylonian Babylon yeah no it
wasn't Babylon yeah well it was
Babylonian yet okay yeah that's the
Babylonian creation story I thought it
was okay Persian uh they have their own
version of it versions of it but it's
like different yeah we're going to get
into that a little bit TM was the mother
Dr that Marduk slay and from a body
created the universe yeah and in a way
if you ask me I believe that that the
dragon in the Book of Revelation is
talking about unrea creation destroying
throwing the dragon into the [__]
Abyss is the same might mean what they
probably talking about Tiamat right
they're talking about God destroys
creation because you don't you don't
need it
anymore in the story yeah well I would
argue that the stories about Leviathan
in the Old Testament are a direct
ripoff or retelling or reboot of the
Tiamat story yeah I would argue because
they're very
similar well much I mean much like uh
you know the Noah's Arc flood story is
kind of a reboot
of the Epic of Gilgamesh which which is
written a lot better which was much
older yeah you you go listen to some
audio books of the Epic of Gil mesh
talking about we read it in school
talking about the flooding of the earth
it's great How the Gods flooded the
Earth because it sucked you know what I
mean y all need to be punished y all
making too much goddamn noise and it's
just so much it's just so much better
than the than the Old Testament Story
the Old Testament is like hillbilly
version of that story it is kind of the
original is written a lot better it is
kind of talks about the agonies of the
people just scrambling up to the rocks
on the highest peaks to get away from
the water and the angels crying what God
has done and oh yeah bad badass [__]
yeah please have mercy on them like no
[__] them they got to go got to go going
to drown all you [__] yeah not a
single goddamn Mone Mak too much goddamn
noise right that's what usually what
happens making too making too much noise
[__] God puts an end to that [__] all
right doesn't matter what God honestly I
can't blame him I mean you know people
are very very noisy yeah well they gave
him fire that's another one yeah yeah
it's like why do we do that that was a
stupid idea gave him fire [__] Zeus says
[__] it look what you look what you did
why' you give them fire now goes the
neighborhood now they got a whole
[__]
cities I'm going to shut this [__] down
okay I don't like it not one bit yeah
not one bit yeah those are like
hilarious stories those are hilarious
stories to me they make sense though if
you're looking at from their point
they're trying to explain where things
came from yeah but like I said so the
Western conception of the Dragon like
you see on Game of Thrones and all that
other kind of stuff usually evil they
usually have wings and all that other
kind of stuff uh whereas the Eastern
dragons they generally don't have wings
uh some of them do but mostly they don't
they're much more Snake like and they
are usually um not necessarily friendly
but they usually represent good luck or
nobility or you know they're they're
good yeah and they're like intelligent
they're real good at Art yeah like
wisdom and stuff like that do some
Artistry they they don't have wings but
they still fly yeah like the Chinese
ones who's always pictured inside a
cloud
and they draw them in a different way
depending on how many talents they had
me things and I think there was more
than one they had I think they had an
entire series of dragon characters yeah
because they well if it had five Talons
only only the emperor was allowed to
wear dragons that have five Talons and
then I think that there was a four
Talent one that was actually pretty cool
and then like the three Talon one was
kind of like okay that was like the
commoner Dragon I guess but weirdly like
the the Japanese dragon like usually had
three
claw too because they got a lot of their
stuff from like um from China as well
but yeah we're going to talk all about
that the Eastern drag Korean dragons all
that kind of stuff like I said I found
all kind of fun stuff yeah they still
flew even though they didn't have wings
they just [__] levitated they were so
cool they
just [__] I'm [__] always I have
always loved like the the Chinese dragon
iconography it's just it's so awesome
and if you look at those they look like
serpents yeah they look much more like
snakes than but the thing about it is
that the Western conception like what we
would recognize as a dragon today that
comes from the Middle Ages yeah it's not
old um like well I mean that's old but
it's not that old like prior to the
Middle Ages dragons looked like lots of
different things and they were generally
more Snake like you know they got like
more beasty as time went on you know
what I mean I think like the O the the
oldest um which I think we'll get into
when we talk about kind of the Indo
European kind of stuff I think the
oldest painting that shows a quote
unquote modern looking dragon is from
like
1260 prior to that they kind of were all
over the place like some of them had
wings some of them not some of them were
kind of snaky some of them not you know
what I mean so it was just kind but the
thing about it is that all dragons no
matter where they come from which again
like I said is very specific see seem to
be an amalgamation of lots of different
animals it usually has kind of like a
snake or reptilian base but then it
usually has a head kind of like a horse
or a lion or something like that and
then sometimes it has feet that are like
bird feet like Eagle feet you know what
I mean so it seems to be like a
combination animal which is something
that is common across all cultures or at
least seems to be so I found that very
interesting as well so as you mentioned
uh the English word
Dragon uh actually didn't enter the
language until the first part of the
13th century and it came from old French
and the old French word which is also
dragon that came from Latin Draco which
is you know the name of the
constellation obviously uh and the word
draco means just big ass serpent big
snake um and in turn the Latin came from
the ancient Greek draon which also means
serpent now I should note that the Latin
and Greek versions of the word they
didn't mean like a mythological creature
they just meant big ass snake pretty
much so anything that looked like a big
serpent was a dragon essentially it
didn't mean it was like a mythological
thing like we would
recognize um interestingly I found this
very
interesting a lot of Scholars and
linguists think that the word dracon the
ancient Greek word might have come from
the Greek word
deri which means I see and they think
that this might be because snakes and
reptiles and stuff like that don't blink
so they thought it was just like always
looking at you right yeah and so like
maybe that's why the word derived from
that I'm not sure if that's the case but
a lot of linguists do seem to think that
which I thought was like really
interesting and they kind of associate
that word with something that has like a
deadly gaze you know what I mean yeah
it's watching yeah so it's like always
watching like I said gaze yeah cuz like
snakes like I said they don't have
eyelid so they can't blink so I thought
that was like really interesting I don't
know they don't need eyelids though they
got a clear yeah clear scale over them
yeah they have an eyelid technically but
it's just clear you can't see it so it
looks like they're just like looking at
you all the time but they're not
actually well I mean I guess they could
be but yeah I think they can shut it
down yeah they probably just like space
out out they dreaming you know like not
I used to have a for a pet I used to
have a um a gecko a Tok Gecko and they
have big ass yellow eyes like that and
they don't have any Lids or anything
over it so they have to constantly lick
their eyeballs like a wiper blade yeah
like a wiper blade yeah like to keep it
it's like it's pretty freaky like
watching it was like kind of neat though
like he's constantly like licking his
eyeballs um but yeah so as I mentioned
probably the oldest written uh stuff
about dragons comes from like the near
East like ancient
Mesopotamia and another thing that again
seems very specific uh and some of these
appear in eastern mythologies too is
that there's lots and lots and lots of
stories of a hero specifically like a
storm God or a Thunder God fighting a
dragon like that's very very common like
I'm pretty sure that like every Western
culture has a story like that and some
Eastern cultures like have a couple of
stories like that too so like again that
seems like a very
specific story like a storm God fighting
a dragon but that's very very common and
we'll talk about some of those like
later on yeah it's weird because uh
Yahweh is a storm God that yeah exactly
after he floods the Earth the rainbow in
the story what they're talking about is
that's it's yahweh's War bow because he
carried a bow and then the depictions so
his his bow was promised that he
wouldn't do it again type of deal yeah
it's funny how there's serpant involved
in that story too his wife was a serpent
yeah Asher she got demoted in in in the
in the New Testament to just the serpent
in the
garden but that's not what she was she
was a goddess that had serpents that's
what it started as it's kind of a
hermaphroditic
symbol somehow it's phallic but it goes
in the earth and makes an egg and comes
out of an egg a male thing that comes
out of an egg and it goes back into the
ground makes another egg and they're
neither male nor female that was they
didn't realize that snakes didn't had
gender right they didn't think though
well it's just kind of like to how
snakes get associated with immortality
because of they the way they shed their
skins yeah um so I think that people
kind of associated those two forever
right so I think that's why they became
a symbol for that and you and like you
said like there's a lot of goddesses
that are have snakes that have snakes or
you know can turn into snakes there's a
lot there's a lot of shape shifting I
didn't realize that there was like some
shape shifting involved in like Dragon
mythology too I don't think they
realized that they laid eggs and they
didn't realize that they had sex yeah
they just thought there was a phallic
shaped thing that went into the ground
and became an egg and then it would come
back out and make babies it would become
a babies you know a whole bunch of
little babies
weird they thought they were reproducing
asexually I guess yeah which some
animals do but snakes are snakes are not
among those animals no they can't every
now and then yeah it depends on the
species um you know but they didn't know
about that though right they were just
looking at it and go man this thing this
this thing this animal didn't have any
junk on it it didn't have a dick or
anything
smooth this thing this thing can't have
sex yeah what's going on with that poor
snake mhm but yeah so yeah that they
didn't really seem to realize that like
some animals that have internal yeah
penises they didn't know that stuff
could unfold they could like pop out
yeah when necessary yeah they didn't
realize that there were holes there they
just couldn't see
it I guess I guess no one was weird
enough to look that
I don't think they question things I
guess not so don't touch it don't look
for it junk what you doing what are you
doing you ass [__] it's obvious
that there's nothing there I think
that's just how they were yeah he's like
look got to be got be in here
somewhere I know he's got one yeah yeah
that was you're crazy he's GNA bite you
holy
[__] but yeah so uh ancient Mesopotamia
Sumeria um you know kind of the
Babylonian uh cultures um they have like
a bunch of different dragon type stories
uh for example there are some poems uh
in
Sumerian and they usually and in this
case dragons are kind of like a good
thing because usually there's like kings
if they're really revered then they're
usually compared to these big like
dragon likee monsters which are called
usal or usal or something like that um
so like I said that seems to be more of
like an Eastern thing which is kind of
interesting there's also a lot of
there's kind of something like a dragon
in the sense that it's kind of an
amalgamation of animals that turns up in
a lot of Mesopotamian artwork from like
2300 to 2100 BCE somewhere around there
um it's kind of like its front part is
kind of like a lion but then its back
part is kind of like a bird and it has
wings on it so it's kind of Griffin kind
of yeah which in some cases are kind of
considered Dragon likee because it's the
same kind of thing because dragons are
also parts of other animals you know
what I mean um this one uh they said the
artwork is they you know they found like
a lot of artwork that has this
particular creature on it and it almost
always has its mouth open and they think
that it might have been known as roaring
weather Beast like not what is it called
not earu something like that but they
think that that might been what that
signified because dragons throughout
pretty much all cultures all cultures
mythology dragons are generally
associated with weather of some kind um
rain storms Thunder something like that
um and a lot of them live in the sea I
think that's it's not so prevalent in
Western cultures although you know some
of the stories have that but in eastern
cultures for real they're like all from
the ocean or the sea or they live in l
sea dragon yeah yeah yeah it's a yeah
it's a similar kind of thing yeah um
yeah so I I so I kind of feel like um a
lot of uh Mesopotamian artwork has these
kind of dragon like creatures that are
kind of like Lion is like lion bird kind
of hybrid things that sort of look like
dragons you know what I mean or some of
them have scorpion Tales too which is
funny to me Chinese dragons look like
cats their faces look like they do and
like a lot of people have said that too
well and like some Western dragons have
faces that kind of look like cats as
well yeah and there's a theory about why
that might be but we'll get into that a
little bit later um so now as we
mentioned before Oh wait I there was
another one too so another one that is
also Mesopotamian um this one probably
the best known one from this time period
is called and I'm sure I'm going to
pronounce this wrong because I looked up
how to pronounce it but I don't remember
what it said
it's m uh mus musu something like that
so which means Furious serpent uh this
is also it kind of looks like a snake
like it has like a neck and like the
body parts of like a snake but then the
front legs are lion legs and then its
back legs are bird legs like Eagle feet
you know what I mean um so this is
basically used to represent various gods
um in the Mesopotamia Pantheon and is
kind of worn for like protection so it
seems kind of positive in this
sense now as we mentioned before there's
also Tiamat now Tiamat was a Babylonian
goddess and she was like the
personification
of chaos or like the chaos before
creation like primeval chaos chaos is
what she represented yeah Cosmic chaos
Dragon yeah it was like the universe
before creation right that's exactly
what she represents and she's like a
before the Big Bang that's what they're
talking about right right right right
pretty much now her story came about uh
in the you know Babylonian uh very
famous Babylonian creation epic the
enuma Elish now she was slain by Marduk
as we mentioned before now now it seems
that there's lots of different
variations of this story in most
variations of the story she does seem to
be described as like a big ass Dragon
because they say she has a big tail and
horns and she has like a hide that you
can't penetrate with weapons and all
that kind of stuff so she's like this
big ass dragon and in the best known
version of the story Marduk kills her
and cuts her up and then uses all her
body parts to like make the world or the
universe right is like what they use but
there are some versions of it where she
seems to be like a person like a woman
but I think the most I don't know the I
think the best known like versions of
the story have her like they describe
her like a big ass Dragon well the
dragon probably in that culture had a
human humanoid personality it was a
goddess talk and there were different
versions like different cultures around
that time period also had stories about
dragons that could morph into people
yeah you know what I mean well like when
we get into like talking about meso
Amica like ketak kadle he could morph
into a person yeah so you're talking
about deities that means superhuman
intelligences from the point of view of
the people that writing them yeah so
they're Supreme Beings yeah yeah so it
could easily imitate a human they could
turn into a person if they want to right
you know I'm just saying so as I
mentioned before in the Old Testament in
the Book of Psalms actually um they talk
about the Leviathan which is just
basically like a big [__] sea monster
right yeah um and Leviathan gets killed
by Yahweh which in the Old Testament is
you know God of Israel and Judah and he
that's kind of part of the creation of
the world also him slaying this big
[__] sea monster which like I said I
kind of feel like the whole Marduk and
Tiamat thing is where that story comes
from because it sounds like a very
similar
narrative um um yeah Leviathan is
probably a serpent sea serpent yeah it's
like a big sea monster some people say
Well they're talking about a whale
probably not probably sea serpent
possible but it's I every depiction of
it that I've seen looks like a big sea
serpent yeah makes sense and in uh job
it actually says that it breathes fire
okay and smoke so it's like a dragon
it's basically a
dragon um and also they kind of make it
pretty clear in the Old Testament too
that Leviathan also not only is just
like a big sea monster but he also
represents Nations that are against
Yahweh it's probably based on Tiamat
that's I that's kind of what I'm
thinking because tat was kind of like uh
the mes early Mesopotamian version of
the
devil it's probably why in the in in the
in the judaic religions the stuff that
came from God of
Abraham dragons are have a demonic tone
to them whenever they're talked about
yeah that's probably what it is they're
talking about
Tiamat and that you and that comes right
from the biblical stories because the
biblical stories tended to take older
quote unquote Pagan stories and whatever
was going on in there said well it's
clearly evil and it just made everything
into like people that wrote the Old
Testament considered the stories of
great floods and the stuff in the Epic
of gilgames to be history yeah that that
that was real they just recast the
characters as their gods yeah that's all
it is it's it's just a re they rebooted
it rebooted it as their gods doing the
parts of the older Gods a lot of times
they're just retelling their favorite
stories because they're going oh
remember that time when this happened
remember that story oh we got to put
that in there this time this is going to
be this is going to be yeah this time
this is going to be you know Ishmael
okay yeah yeah he's gonna do it you know
it's just reboots they're just reboting
they're just rebooting they're just
taking like the old stories they like
and like you said and a lot of times um
anything that was I kind of feel like
the the stories maybe prior to the
biblical stories were more morally
ambiguous generally um whereas the
biblical stories tried to make them
more you know they were trying to make
it like you know one God and this is the
one you got to worship and [__] like
that so it's like everything other than
that they're just going to make that bad
kind of I mean gener t stuff is so vague
you don't know what the [__] that the
moral lesson was that's true that's true
because it's so old it's not relevant
anymore so you don't know what the
lesson was they were trying to tell you
and it's just cobbled together like I
said from various stories that were
floating around during that time but a
lot of Roman stuff's like that too we
have all kinds of Roman fables and
stories and religious stories that they
had for their gods and you can plainly
read the story but you don't know what
the story actually was tried to teach
you right you know maybe back then they
knew back then they knew but but now
we're just like what right yeah the hell
are you talking about they're trying to
teach you some kind of a Mor morality
that was important to them yeah but you
we don't even see
it yeah because I mean we don't have the
context
obviously you
know yeah Ben says in Dungeons and
Dragons oh and yeah I remember this too
Tiamat is an arch devil and the deity of
evil dragons that's right but she has
lost command of her own layer of hell
and now has responsibility for guarding
the first layer from uninvited guests
that's right I remember that from when I
used to play D and D when I was much
much younger but yeah I do remember that
I think she was even on the cover of one
of the books I thought that my brother
had it was a long time
ago um DVD Dragon said Christians took
stories from older pagan religions and
use them again like reheated Pizza yeah
yeah pretty much yeah a lot of that lot
of the stuff in the New Testament is
dianis stories that kind of came from
dionis some of some of it came from U um
Cult of Mithra or mithraism was a
Persian religion one of these days we
should do a show about myis too because
that's fascinating also the whole idea
of a Last Supper that came from mithis
and the and uh 12 disciples at the Last
Supper that's some mithraism yeah and
it's funny that nor Norse mythology has
a version of that too actually and
what's funny is that there's 12
disciples but there's also 12 signs of
the zodiac and that all that [__] was
tied in they understood it in ways that
we don't yeah and a lot of it had to do
with
numerology because the Romans were big
into
numerology and Christianity is a Roman
religion and it's been influenced by the
religious competitors it had one of the
main one was Cult of
mithis and it absorbed cult Cult of
mithis it stole a lot of its [__]
people probably a lot of its followers
so the story is kind of
merged so now you have stories with
Jesus in them but he's doing things that
mithis did you know even the same number
of
followers because it was because
mithraism was it was from Persia and it
was real big into the signs of the
zodiac it was kind of like Scientology
evidently it's been totally w wiped out
from history but some things survive
about it it seems to have been like
Scientology where you leveled up you had
to do certain things and you would level
up and it had something to do with C
knowing your horoscope knowing what sign
you were born in knowing you know what
was you know was was Taurus inside
Sagittarius on this month how's that
going to affect you they were doing that
but it was a christian-like religion at
the same time Christianity seems to have
absorbed some of that early Christianity
it's in the stories only they didn't
have those practices though those
probably gone a couple hundred years
later but I would imagine early
Christianity probably had a lot of damn
astrology in it too oh big time yeah
well and like I said I'm just fascinated
by that I love comparative mythology
that kind of [__] like fascinates me
yeah so it's like I just love like where
stories came from and all definitely had
numerology in it oh yeah seven s S7 six
666 12 over and over and over again 72
is over and over and over again even
Islam has 72 72 virgins yeah so um
originally there were 72 sons of [__]
well that was actually Old Testament 72
sons of el Shai or God Almighty one of
them was Yahweh he chose
Israel and the sons of God made had sex
with the daughters of men creating the
Nephilim
so in other words they're talking about
same situation in the Greek pantheon you
had father of the Gods all his sons and
they're cracking all the [__]
beautiful females making demigods yeah
like Perseus and [__] and and and and
and Heracles well Jesus was that Jesus
was a Demag God yeah a Roman Demag God
same kind of his father was God and the
mother was Mary that's same as Hercules
was just a random lady his dad was Zeus
and his mom was some hot chick and I
think Zeus [__] her in the form of a
bull didn't he he did indeed he [__] he
was always Chang like he was like why be
a man when you going to knock it down
become a bull all 16 Ines of you yeah
yeah he was he was a swan sometimes and
a [__] shower of gold shower of gold
I don't know how that works shower of
gold nowadays that's like what you see
in the porn flick where they're throwing
the dollar bills on the girl like that
when she's doing her act okay back in
back in Roman days it was a shower of
gold I was imagining give it up baby
give it up give it up I was imagin twerk
just like a shower of gold coins like
going like shooting into someone's [__]
no raining down Make It Rain okay Make
It Rain it's it's as old it's as old as
time you put that hoe out there and just
make it rain on she'll give it up that's
that's what God did in the old Roman
religion so that's right Twerk
it he could just be a shower gold he
didn't even a dick or nothing yeah yeah
just a bunch of money falling on her
how'd this Swan thing work out I wonder
cuz it's just some [__] you know what I
mean all pretty and [__] that's if he's
going to get soft with them he's you
know what I mean although I think Swan
now he'd come at you like in the form of
Prince but back then they just turning
in in the form of a swan
yeah yes you never know you never you
never know who how he might turn up you
never
know oh when he's manly he's going to
come when he's hyper masculine he's
going to come at you with a bull hard on
and
everything religious stories are awesome
they they are kind of because they're
very telling on the people who wrote
them in the culture so you know exactly
what they were like when I was growing
up I I always thought like Greek myths
were so fun yeah I just I love that [__]
like all the people like turning it into
animals and doing all kind of like this
shit's crazy this is awesome well the
Greeks and the Romans basically was
Maximum Security Prison that's like
something you see in Maximum Security
Prison you know men having sex with
other men because they were less
masculine than you right you know and
then and then they would do it with
women too and then animals and all kinds
of weird [__] and then Animal Human
hybrids yeah that was very big yeah it
was very big but they didn't really see
any problem with it no they were just
like ah whatever and then if you got out
of line they just [__] killed you
because they were higher ranked than you
right A lot of people don't realize that
murder was legal in Rome as long as you
killed somebody who was lower ranked
than you so it's like the
mafia yeah yeah I don't think I think
you could even kill a citizen if you
were a
Lord that yeah that that you just kill
him yeah what' you kill him for he was
being an [__] oh okay all right cuz I
didn't like his [__] that was law
enforcement back then you had to [__]
obey people that were higher station
than you yeah I don't like
that everybody was a cop yeah I don't
like that you had to [__] mind your
[__] p's and q's evidently yeah but I
mean you could just be walking around
like not just minding your own [__]
beeswax and somebody decide they don't
like you for some reason well Emperors
were always [__] shiding the rich
people for [__] abusing power you it
says you're not supposed to be mean to
people you're supposed to be have high
standards and you know you're supposed
to be Noble and [__] um they were having
problems they were having problems
litigating or they were having problems
passing laws having to do with morality
you can't really legalize morality or
like let litigate what do you call
it it's hard to force people to be
moral you know they did have certain
basic rights I think even slaves had
certain rights but not many they uh you
had the power of life and death over
over slaves that you owned in your house
yeah well I think that's been true
throughout the entire history of slavery
yeah up until the relatively Romans were
ruthless though if the if anybody in the
house was killed and a slave did it all
slaves were put to death and that
actually caused riots in the city they
were like because it was it was but they
were all what you did is they they held
all the slaves hostage with each
other yeah know
yeah uh when I was talking about um all
the Christianity like ripping off all
the old quote unquote Pagan stories yeah
Tammy said just like now remaking movies
people can't come up with an original
story yeah it's always been like that um
they're just kind of like hey I I like
that story I'm going to retool that but
I'm going to put my own kind of spin on
it I don't think it was fraudulent
though well no they were just doing I
don't think they thought anything about
it there was no concept of like
intellectual property or anything like
that it's just like you you heard
stories and it's like you know I think
the people that actually wrote those
stories were Pious Believers of the
religions that they were they were they
they believed the older stories had
happened yeah but they were but those
Rel th but those stories came from a
religion that was older than the one
that they were in they wanted to tell
that
story but they didn't want to propagate
that older
religion so what they did is they
reinterpreted the old story this was a
good story it was from God so but the
rest of it was wrong so then you now you
reboot that story with God in it your
version of God you change some names
just change some names and you say
that's from God God says that's cool God
said it was cool yeah he told me and I
don't think it was Pious deception but
you know I think they were honest or
they were trying to be honest with it
well they probably just thought well
they kind of had the right idea but now
we know better like cuz our God's
clearly the right one
yeah right that's that's exactly what
they were doing that's exactly what they
just didn't know but they didn't know
what God was trying to tell them right
yeah that's what Z say that's actually
kind of happens in the Old Testament
yeah the burning bush when Moses sees
the burning bush he says I am basically
he says I am the god almighty and I uh I
am the one that you know um uh that your
forefather uh [__] Abraham worshiped
before you and I am your lord you know
I'm yeh I'm Yahweh your lord basically
that's what he says I just want par what
he's saying is he says oh by the
way your forefathers knew me as El Shai
but I'm actually
Yahweh and I'm also Baal the original
translation says because Lord also
translates as
baale so if you read it in the original
Greek it's
saying I'm El
Shai Moses know Abraham worshiped me he
was your forefather but I'm actually
Yahweh and baale so all the stories
about Yahweh that you have and all the
stories about Bale that's me
too we I was El Shai all the along but
you call me Yahweh he's taking the mask
off like at the end of SC they did that
even back in the days yeah it's like
it's pretty hilarious like when you say
because you know people aren't any
different back then Zan said the real
forgotten religion is Zoroastrianism I
have a little bit about that um because
they do have like some Persian or
zoroastrian
yeah I thought Marduk was in zoroastrian
no it's Babylonian it's older which was
the one that was in which the one that
had Marduk had Zoroastrianism that was
I've got it like farther down in my
notes okay there's a dragon in that one
too there is a dragon in it yeah uh Ben
said in the New Testament the Christians
started equating dragons with Satan and
with serpents yep uh that's exactly what
happened yeah but it wasn't just them
yeah the the Mesopotamians believed that
because of Tiamat so they just inherited
that idea
said they still find hidden temples to
mithis every now and then yeah they do
all your early all your the Vatican and
all those early churches in Europe
they're built on mithraic temples the
the churches seem to have merged they
were merged for a while and then what's
funny is that all the mithraic stuff
underneath the bottom of the some of
those Catholic churches in Rome still
have all that Mythic [__] sculpture
they didn't the priests didn't tear it
down you you think the Christian priests
would have they didn't yeah they let it
be there cuz they respected it it was
handed down to
them and probably because somebody in
Antiquity realized that the two churches
had merged yeah and one of the [__]
freezes that is
there is a [__] picture of the Last
Supper mithis is there with a table of
12 disciples eating
but it's not the same story we have and
that's not Jesus
yeah well you
know there's a bit they got everything
came from yeah myth is crawling out of a
hole in a rock and then something
happens to them and then it has
something to do with the story yeah I
can't even
remember yeah a cave like I said we
should probably do a show about that one
of these days I read a book about it a
long time ago but I he slay he slays a
bull yeah yeah and there's a lot of um
there's a lot of sculptures of him doing
that yeah that they come across every
now and then and then the Bull's being
attacked and it's got a scorpion
stinging the bull in the balls and
there's a dog that's got it by its nose
and it's all it's a whole thing yeah
it's all uh astrological signs you know
Scorpio and Taurus
yeah yeah astrology was kind of a big
deal astrology yeah Ben said there was a
trick involving prostitutes catching
coins while handstanding in Roman
brothel oh yeah yeah that's pretty good
actually the ping pong ball trip just
reverse but somebody just like throwing
a coin like how baggy would your [__]
have to be to like have I don't know I
don't know we can try it Jim we can try
it we'll get you want me do a handstand
stand I'll put the tripod up that'll be
the next video we make trying to get a
coin in there but I throw a quarter yeah
I don't think that's going to work out
to got two new videos up on got two new
videos up on Mini vids in the car and J
on the park
B yeah I finally put those up they're up
there yeah I only put them on many vids
though because you were in them like
your voice was in that I can't put them
up on so I can't put them up on
streamate yeah but uh but yeah and it's
funny we're this intelligent we still
make
porn intelligence and porn doesn't have
anything to do you don't do the [__] for
money you do the [__] for fun yeah you
just do the [__] for fun I I was having
a good time that's
all uh yeah we're this intelligent and
we still that's hilarious that's another
t-shirt we need to make you do it for
kicks man do it for [__] Street Crib
That's what I mean we just do it for fun
we don't like you know I don't make a
[__] ton of money on it it's just you
know we just do it because we want to
yeah uh Ben said most of the myth Cycles
are borrowed Norse mythology is a
retelling of Greek Legends yep that's
true and AR3 and legends are retelling
of Christ and the apostles yep that is
absolutely true as well like I said
everybody just reboots so I don't know
why people piss and moan about it
nowadays because people have been doing
that since humans have existed you know
what I mean most most religions have
like uh you know I'm one of I'm one of
the people that kind of really want
really interested in the origins of
Islam I'm going to try to look I have a
[__] funny feeling that that that's
not as historical as as the account is
we know how religions are
born the closest thing we know of that
sounds like the story of
Muhammad would be Joseph Smith yeah
Joseph Smith from uh Mormonism
Mormonism we know that that happened
because there's government records and
he did exist and it's a crazy tale that
was a real dude but mean and he and he
was called the American Muhammad in his
lifetime and he approved of that title
he was copying Muhammad almost
everything about him was copy of
Muhammad even tablets and Angel [__]
giving him the tablets yeah where do you
think he got all those ideas got the
idea it's not as weird as it seems yeah
it's just it seems weird because it's
filtered through an American yeah like a
modern American lens yeah so it seems
weird because it's not like ancient you
know what I mean I'm skeptical it's kind
of the same story skeptical of
Islam I don't think that's a story I
don't think that's how it happened
because it it Islam appears fully formed
in Western
history there's no account of early a
new religion and a bunch of Warriors
taking Christian land and a new Prophet
there's no mention of that in any
Western history there just a mention of
desert
Warriors they believe in somebody called
Muhammad but that seems to be later
after it happened but we don't
know I think it was the Christians I
think it was all
Christians I think Muhammad might have
been a Christian then later after he won
these wars if he was real because it
sounds like King Arthur too but then
after he won the wars he then changed
Islam changed Christianity into Islam
after the war I think something like
that yeah maybe so I mean you know we
could we could get into changed not get
in trouble Man [__] trying to
kill me no was going to try to kill
you it's all right Tammy says smart
people like sex also that's true yes
that's absolutely true they have
imagination they come up
crazy yeah yeah maybe maybe we'll try
that maybe oh that's actually be a good
idea to do videos based on weird Greek
mythology you know what I mean takes too
much money too much effort you could do
like I said the whole shower gold thing
that would be like that'd be [__]
funny I'll just get that damn gun that
shoots dollar bills out shoot dollar
bills
on
yeah
okay that works yeah all right I might
need another drink but before we uh well
I was going to say before you go cuz
we're going to get into Egyptian
mythology now all right so do you want
me to wait for you yeah just wait a
second okay so some questions or
something all right so let me go back to
see if there was said room sounds
awesome I mean room sounds awesome if
you um had a bunch of money and power
everyone else probably not so
much you know like you just walking down
the street and you like look at somebody
find or do something they didn't like
and they're just like hey I don't even
like you so bam and like they just get
away with it that is like that's [__]
up Z also said I've studied a lot about
Islam All That Old Middle East history
is fascinating it really is I really
need to get more into that like Tom
watches a lot of stuff about that I was
like I've read a lot about um the
origins of Christianity the origins of
like lots of different religions because
like I said I like comparative mythology
so I'm really interested how all of that
all this stories fit together but I
haven't looked into Islam like all that
much you know what I
mean
um yeah um let me see Iris says uh
Muhammad has been taught to read also
depends on interpretation on individuals
too but he's buried in Medina Saudi
Arabia
um yeah that's right okay yeah doing a
show on the Crusades would be good yeah
um I had thought about doing a show
about the Crusades that might like be
that might be a
gargantuan task but there so many of
them that's what I mean it's like we
might have to like narrow it down what
you want to do want to do a show on the
Children's Crusade how ridiculous that's
yeah yeah yeah cuz yeah you'd have to
like pick one so I kind of feel like
yeah because I've always been fascinated
by the Children's Crusade cuz what the
[__] was that even all about but yeah um
we should probably actually maybe I
should write that down because I don't
think that's on my list I have a huge
list you guys you don't even understand
like every time one of you mention
something if I remember I write it down
and then I will try to put it in the
polls but I don't think we've ever done
one
on we'll do like the Children's Crusade
because like I said that's kind of the
most [__] up one and that was the one
when I learned about it in school I'm
just like you've got to be [__]
kidding me right now um let's see uh
gonna do the Greek thing do the bull
thing then yeah well well it could be a
pretend bull it doesn't have to be a
real one obviously because that would be
like that would be bad
um yeah Erica said Catholic churches
used to cover old temples that had Pagan
things with a church over top yeah
that's right they did uh common theme it
was said to contain the Pagan ideas of
what was considered evil to Christians
yeah that's where and as far as I can
remember that's where they found a lot
of um mithraic stuff um
underneath like you know later like
Christian churches or Catholic churches
or something like that like cuz they
would build it over it's like we're just
going to pretend that that's not there
you know what I mean so they did that
kind of
crap and let me see nightmares and
rainbow said I saw a documentary that
um I'm not sure what that word supposed
to be but um the the Egyptian god Set
was one of the gods that inspired the
Christian God yeah there were a lot um
there was just a lot of stuff going
around at that time like I said it's
just
all it's kind of like the Marvel
Universe it was kind of like the Marvel
Universe yeah you know it that sounds
that sounds glib but that's what it's
like that's what humans come up with
like Heroes that are larger than life
and stuff like that it was the same [__]
that was going on back then they just
didn't have movies a good
example is
Superman and
Superman you had a Heavenly Father his
name was Jerel l l is the name of you
know El Shai this is the abrahamic god
he had a son
hi poy
K that was Superman comes down from
heaven he's raised on Earth to be a
savior of
mankind all right he's at a place called
Metropolis all right he can do all these
great things he can even
fly thousands of years from now somebody
would see that might think that that'd
be a
religion yeah you know and that maybe
Metropolis was a real
place you know yeah thinking that they
must be talking about New York new maybe
New York at one time was called
Metropolis it's not it's totally made up
out of somebody's head a Jewish kid
wrote that story somebody who ran from
Germany during the during the you know
preh Holocaust the Nazis took over his
his
family skirted him away to America [__]
this that's the same that's the same way
kalell came here you know what I mean h
Krypton was being destroyed and his
family sends him to a new place to
America so you could say in a way
Superman existed it was the boy that
wrote that story yeah it's kind of about
him but then you go does that mean
Superman was real no Superman could fly
he could shoot lasers out of his eyes
all right he could go back in time by
like going around the earth a bunch of
times right so right well you run you
run into that same problem you start
talking about Jesus and say well he was
just these stories are just written
around a preacher some Street Preacher
that was got real famous now it's more
likely they just made him up or he's
just like I said like an amalgamation of
a bunch of different every one of those
stories is dianis or [__] some of the
[__] he says sounds kind of like
Socrates everything that he did yeah
somebody else did somebody else did
before
that so yeah there was no historical
Jesus they just cobbled it together from
like different stories that were going
around at the time or that were older
I'm convinced there's no historical
Jesus there's no no I don't think there
was there's nobody there but yeah and
like I said I'm not trying to be
offensive or anything like that but it's
just kind of like I don't think he was a
real person he was just an amalgamation
of a bunch of other there are Roman
records no they're not there are no
Roman records there's no Roman records
like I said every single thing he did
yeah like an older yeah mythological
figure did that too there's a reference
in some copies of Josephus it was
obviously inserted later into the book
of Jose Josephus the Antiquities of the
Jew that's an interpolation it's an
interpolation they went back and wrote
that in there because it's not in all
editions they did that a lot back then
and it's a damn advertisement for
Christianity oh and by the way this time
there was a man named Jesus and he was
Son of God and he was there commercial
they put yeah yeah yeah right well hold
on we've covered and this is in a
history book [__] out of there man
Church put that in there yeah it's
pretty much yeah yeah nobody knew who
Jesus was until a hundred years after he
supposedly lived let me know who that
dude was and 100 years is a long time
like and especially back then yeah
because they didn't really have like a
lot of Records like we have now yeah the
Christian churches you know it was
actually like from the second century
early third Century yeah yeah long time
after it happened that's all and there
wasn't one Christianity there was
Christian many of them comp yeah they
were all competing yeah and they were
all hokey it didn't really get codified
until much later much later like
400 well 350 somewhere around at 253 F
around that we're not sure there are no
real old
Bibles oldest Bibles I think that they
actually have as full complete Bibles I
think are
medieval but you have scraps of them
from the Roman times but just like a
piece of a page that's
it High Desert said you should check out
uh neoplatonism and how it influenced
all the major religions that might be
another thing that we could look into
because that's probably pretty
interesting as well
so uh all right so let's get back to the
dragons I mean we're still talking about
mythology so we're not that far off
topic but I wanted to wait for you
because you had said that Egyptian
mythology didn't have dragon stories but
then I remember but it does apep apep is
kind of the main one yeah so he was
basically which I mean you could call
him a dragon he's like a big ass I
always pictured him as an alligator he's
like a big snake or like a big crocodile
type of creature he's in the Underworld
yeah he lives in the the do which is the
underworld yeah the well the do wasn't
really the underworld it was the
Horizon underneath the Horizon so yeah
the Underworld the underworld yeah the
place where the sun goes into under the
ground at night yeah yeah that's where
they're talking about and and there's
hell underneath there right like the old
like older stories say that when the sun
sets that's raw going into the
underworld to fight apep yeah and he got
to do that [__] every day he's got to go
down there and fight a dragon and to
bring sunlight to give relief to the
Damned yeah yeah cuz he was merciful you
were in hell but he's going to bring you
some Son yeah okay give you a little bit
of relief yeah here you go I'm coming to
visit hey and then he comes up on the
other side of the D comes up out of the
ground with a whole Heavenly procession
of stars and Lords and gods behind him
you know them the Stars cuz he's got to
make a big [__] deal about everything
he's got a whole [__] parade behind
him of people up in the Stars Kings and
gods yeah see I love all those [__]
stories about like the description of
like the sun and the stars and the moon
and everything like going across the
heavens like just the the stories they
came up with to explain that are like so
awesome yeah God of Abraham religions
Christianity
Judaism Islam they all have the Egyptian
Universe model you have a flat Earth
with Four Corners to it it sits on
pillars that holds the Earth up we don't
know what the pillars are sitting on a
turtle sits on yeah sitting on Turtle
then you got a damn fundament which is a
[__] Dome ceiling on it all right
with stars that are set in it and I
guess it moves all right and the sun
goes down underneath the ground and it
comes up the other side that's the
Egyptian model uhhuh yeah the sun just
goes underneath the table It Go and the
Earth is not go underneath the table
comes up the other side yeah he fights a
dragon all night and then I guess he
defeats the Dragon for or knocks a
dragon out or something then he's like
I'm back all right so here I go across
the sky again it's like oh [__] now I'm
gonna fight the dragon again it's like
every day that's why you have in in in
the the Bible even in the New Testament
they says and the stars fall from the
sky and they fall to the Earth so
they're picturing a star like the size
of a coin right real shiny but it's up
little did they know it's up in the
fundament the foundation of the sky
and the Waters of the sky this is very
confusing to a modern person the
fundament was the [__] solid ceiling
that the stars were [__] set
into but if you looked at the ocean it
was blue or green and it went to the
[__] Horizon and then went up over
the Earth so you had the Waters of the
sky that's why the sky was blue and
that's why it rained that makes total
sense rain fell from the [__] ceiling
sometimes but the water was up there so
that was and then you know you had the
heavens of the nighttime
sky I don't know if the water was still
up there at night you'd probably have to
consult some old sages from the times
but I guess it was cuz it could rain
curious because at night I was I was
picturing it being like a lightbrite
yeah you know what I mean like it was a
piece of black paper that had like
little light bulbs like stuck into it
that's what I was pict well in that one
in in that one [__] Book of
Revelations where it says the star fell
from the [__] Sky I'm imagining
[__] Romans and Christians and Jews
running around picking all these Stars
up trying to sell them how much is a
[__] star worth that'd be some
hardcore jewelry it would yeah shiny as
[__] sh more shiny than any diamond how
much would a star weigh per
ounce how big are they are they the size
of a [__] headlight of a car if a
star really hit the earth we would be in
big trouble oh star can't hit the earth
know the Earth is pulled into the star
and vaporized before it ever gets to
before it ever they didn't realize how
big they were that's well they you know
I mean in their with some exceptions
they look real little with with some
exceptions yeah educated Greeks and
Romans knew that the Earth was a sphere
and that all that [__] was far away and
that there were
planets they it was a heliocentric Earth
though they thought the Earth was in the
center yeah well of I think some people
later on were saying no it must be but I
don't think they really proved that to
the Medieval Era yeah and you could get
yourself killed talking about it oh yeah
big time right but I think I remember
correctly some
Greeks thought the sun was at the center
of the earth they Center some of them
did know that yeah yeah but you didn't
want to tell that it's just kind of like
even when you know
when when we were in school like and
they were saying even when Columbus like
you know did his voyages or whatever
like oh everybody thought the Earth was
flat they no they didn't no they didn't
that is a misconception educated people
all the way up educated people knew it
was knew it was round uh educated people
knew the diameter of the Equator of the
Earth the
diameter of the Moon how far away the
moon was how what the diameter of the
Sun was and how far away it was they
knew that too they did it by tracking
shadows and using geometry yeah they
knew how far away that was and how big
that was I mean they're like probably in
a lot of ways they didn't have a lot of
the technology obviously that we have
nowadays so it's like they had to figure
that [__] out on their own did that [__]
by mathematics
yeah so in some ways they were probably
smarter yeah they were [__] smarter
because they didn't have anything to
like [__] lean on you know what I
mean and they had to figure out when the
sun was overhead how the differences
between the Shadows between long
distances so you could take the angles
of the Shadows at long distances you had
to knew the exact time and then by mail
said well how big was that shadow over
there when it at noon okay but this one
over here was [__] 3 ft long so then
they could back asmith yeah how far away
the sun was the diam the diameter of the
earth and the diameter of the sun yeah
they figured all that [__] out figured
it all out a long time ago yeah I think
we talked about that some when we did a
show about flat earthers yeah who I'm
not convinced are like all of them are
trolling but I'm not really sure cuz
some people are that stupid I think some
of them are trolling oh I'm sure some of
them are trolling but some of them are
just stupid yeah they want to believe I
guess like what what did they gain out
of that though I'm not really sure like
what you would gain by thinking the
Earth was flat faith I guess yeah oh I
know some [__] that other people I I can
like Lord it over people because I think
everyone else is stupid I'm like no it's
just you that's stupid so you know good
job was talking about Hitler grabbing
the their mustache man mustache man
grabbing the [__] Spear of Destiny
they did get that the thing is it was a
fake well yeah and well the thing about
it is that I think all the relics were
fake sure and I and I think that there
was like a perception that it's like oh
well they're looking for all these
religious relics so obviously it would
behoove you to like come up with some
fakes if you were able to do that to
correct firmament not fundament yeah you
keep saying fundament and I'm like that
sounds like you're talking about
somebody's Tain F the firmament was at
the top every time you say that yeah I'm
just kind of like that's right all I'm
thinking of is like somebody's taint or
man these are [__] these are [__]
relig terms man they don't mean anything
no firmament no foundation in the sky
like I said it's not like a light bright
up there with black paper with little
bulb stuck into it which is what I
always picture you know what I mean yeah
um it's me Jay said flat earther just
want to be contrary yeah I think a lot
of them do I think a lot of them do but
like I said don't they have better
things to do at their time I guess not
but um you know I don't know we did a
show about them and I'm just kind of
like whatever they don't piss me off as
much as creationists but it's kind of in
the same boat you know what I mean we
haven't done a show about Evolution and
creationist but if you want to see me
get real mad uh we should do a show
about that one of these days because
those people really piss me off but um
but yeah so what were we talking about
okay so we're talking about apep who
like I said technically a dragon right
um apep is generally described as being
eight people tall like eight men tall
which is pretty long right uh also has a
head made out of lint so there's that um
also um there were like when there were
earthquakes or thunderstorms or
something like that um supposedly it was
apep roaring that caused that and
whenever there was a solar eclipse that
was when apep decided to come out the
underworld and attack raw during the
daytime okay yeah so that was when she's
oh I'm coming to get you [__] so
yeah that was that going yeah the Aztecs
had a beat though they could predict
when they were going to happen
I think they knew what it was they
definitely could could track the cycles
of it
yeah they destroyed a lot of [__] from
the Mexican civilization I wouldn't
surprise me that if the priests actually
knew that there were that the Earth was
spherical and and that a shadow was
being cast on the
earth honestly they probably did figure
that out yeah they wouldn't have told
the people that would have been top
secret information they probably figured
that out though yeah because you could
use it yeah you could say we we're going
to make the sun we're going to make the
[__] sun disappear yeah cuz why
wouldn't you if you knew it was going to
happen and nobody else did be like [__]
I'm magic yeah Watch What Happens always
cry something the sun's running out of
energy it's going to [__] go dark and
we're going to bring it back yeah after
we kill all these people and blood all
that throw all them hearts out of there
you watch it'll come back then they do
it goes away and they're scared shitless
and they start [__] cutting people's
hearts out and [__] then it comes
back says see it worked and then they
they all the people believe in them they
said give all the credit to your king
that's exactly you listen to him that's
what I would do that's what they did
yeah I can see I can see you doing that
yeah you're like oh we fig well how are
you going to control them man are
savages they cut people's hearts
out you can't tell them the truth true
yeah I gotta yeah they they were Aztecs
were badasses man they were hostile
though but they were very Ed they were
they lived well though you listen you
got read hernand Cortez's [__]
testimonies they said they were scared
shitless of them they were scared of
them yeah and and they didn't destroy
the Aztec they just fomented a damn
Rebellion from all the vassel states
that the Aztecs had formed you know the
Aztecs were badasses man they ruled that
land with the iron fist well and I feel
like the more [__] goes on it's like the
more we realize how complex and enormous
That civilization was yeah
and we and so much of it is lost which
is like that's really shitty I mean
hopefully more of it is out there like
it was more
complicated and more sophisticated than
feudal Japan and feudal Japan was pretty
[__]
sophisticated um but it wasn't a bunch
of Waring States it was an Empire and it
had a vast library of uh according to
the uh Dominican Friars that were there
contacting the the the Vatican they say
we shouldn't destroy all this [__] this
is a [__] vast wealth of [__]
literature knowledge and they're being
to no burn
it the only thing they saved was like
the Dresden Codex and a couple of other
things that just makes me so sad
whenever I hear about that it's just
like that's a whole [__] civilization
that we'll never know about that now
even the Catholics priests that were
there on site or say no you you
shouldn't be throwing this away no
telling what they actually knew yeah all
their little secrets I mean CU I think
they kept a lot of Secrets From The
Common People yeah I mean you know
that's I imagine their science was
probably pretty Advanced yeah they
weren't in the iron or steel age yet but
they didn't have the that [__] in the it
wasn't in their culture they didn't know
about it
right all right so um I told you that a
pep probably the best known uh dragon
type creature from Egyptian mythology
but there were a couple of other ones
too matter of fact there was one that
was kind of a good guy who was a giant
Serpent and his name was let me see if I
can pronounce this correctly um neab cow
something like that um and he was
supposed to like guard the underworld
and helps out raw whenever raw has to go
fight AP pep so he was kind of like a
good guy um and he was so big that the
whole earth was supposed to like sit in
his little snake coils there so yeah so
he was like a big [__]
snake there was also another one called
denn who was a big giant snake and he
was like a snake but his body was like
fire like made of fire and supposedly
he was messing around one day and like
caused this big huge Blaze and almost
killed all the other Egyptian gods
oopsie um and he got killed by
pharaoh and that's how Pharaoh got the
Divine Right to rule by killing this big
giant fire snake you know what I mean so
yeah so Egyptian mythology also has
dragon stories about it there's also the
oroboros um which you know nowadays you
no look like a snake swallowing its own
tail but the early version of that which
is Egyptian was called the many faced
and it was a snake essentially with five
heads and it was supposed to go around
raah and like protect
him um and there's actually an Ora boros
they found in like King tutt's tomb like
that's the oldest one that they' found
so far um later on the oroboros got
adopted by the gnostics Gnostic
Christians and later became like a
alchemical symbol like in the Middle
Ages at which point they made it look
more like a dragon or like what you
would recognize as a dragon
today um and here we are mentioning a
little bit about
Zoroastrianism uh so this was from
Persia and this is a giant snake or
Great Snake called AI
Daka and this was a dragon um pretty
much an evil dragon like a demonic kind
of figure um he had three
heads and um so this was kind of like
one of the main zoroastrian dragons
there was also another kind of Persian
story about um an Iranian SLP Persian
hero named rosan
and he has to slay a dragon who is 80 M
long which was also invisible or could
become invisible I guess and it was him
and his horse whose name was Rox and he
was going to fight this dragon with him
and his horse so rosan even though he's
supposed to go fight a dragon he falls
asleep I guess we all got to sleep
sometimes maybe has narcolepsy I don't
really know so the dragon comes up to
him and the horse tries to wake him up
but can't and so sleeping his ass off
right it's just kind that's what I
thought this he didn't mention that
fifth that he drank before maybe that's
what it was yeah yeah oh yeah I gotta
fight that
Dragon got to catch some sh sh I'll do
it later I got to rest I got to rest
yeah but yeah so um so finally like the
horse tries to wake him up but can't but
then like finally like rossan wakes up
and he like oh [__] he like here's the
dragon the horse bites the dragon um and
then I guess is able to distract the
dragon long enough for Ros to like cut
its head off and this was actually there
was a a Iranian Persian um story that
was I guess kind of like the Heracles
type of story where he had like all of
these labors or things that he had to do
um he had seven labors and this was one
of them where he had to go like slay
this particular Dragon so I thought that
was like kind of interesting too so
that's very similar to the kind of Greek
stories now we've got into a part in the
in in the show where I can
say a lot of people would think that
maybe dragons were based upon
dinosaurs I don't think so I think
they're
totally a fictional religious icon that
really
came from way back in the day serpents
they're talking about serpents big magic
serpents they evolved into what we would
consider a dragon yeah so they're
talking about serpents and I don't think
it had anything to do
with Dinosaurs yeah I mean we'll get
into that a little bit later on yeah I'm
not really sure I buy that there's a
bunch of other stories about ancient
Greeks and finding dinosaur fossils and
their take on them had nothing to do
with
Dragons because they didn't find as far
as we know anything like a damn head of
a Tyrannosaurus rex or anything most of
the fossils they found were things like
giant sloths stuff like that which still
which are still kind of scary old but
and then their their explanation was
nothing close to what you would think a
dragon would be it's a griffin that kind
of stuff it's an Amazon that's that's
that's other [__] explanations they
had so I don't think dragons have
anything to do with
dinosaurs and I don't think they have
anything to do with the
alligators now you did say earlier that
and I've heard this as well and maybe
there's something to this but that the
ancient Greek conception of for example
a cyclops yeah might have come from
elephant skull
yeah I didn't say it on the show earlier
I said it during I said it yeah that's
what I meant you said it earlier like
this morning like when we were talking
about they found an old um cuz elephant
skulls do kind of look like it's just
like one big eye because where the trunk
comes out you know what I event they
found a Big Crypt that was made by the
Greeks the Greeks and it on the Crypt it
was basically showing a here you know
that was the burial of a hero or Cyclops
or giant or something and they opened it
up and it was a damn elephant and the
way they had it laid out it was like a
human right with the elephant skull
there it didn't have tusks I don't think
but where the elephant trunk comes from
there's a big opening there it looks
like an eye socket looks like a big eye
socket yeah and I think they thought
that was a an ey socket to
a cyclops like a big ass man with one
eye yeah one big had him like he was a
man laying in there and
um it was a fossil of some kind of
Mammoth or something I believe or
elephant and they gave him buried him
with full honors when they found him and
their explanation he had died in some
fight and he was a great warrior you
know with one big ass [__] Cyclops
thing and then it was probably a uh
tourist attraction hey come [__] pay
the respects and [__] the Crypt of
this [__] big old Cyclops I mean they
might have known that was an elant or
something but they were just kind of
like hey it's $5 like or five dmire or
whatever it is like come here and see
this big like it might have been it
might have been kind of like a like a
Ripley Believe It or Not kind of
situation it wasid they weren't dumb it
was evidently pretty well made where
where they had it buried the the little
sarcophagus that it was
in but they also seem to think that it
was a tourist attraction right or a
religious Shrine yeah I buy that all
right it could have been you know the
Greeks had natural scientists it could
have been they looked at it and there
may be a chance that they went no I
think this is is an
elephant I don't know if the Greeks knew
about elephants but they they they their
knowledge spread pretty
wide but there's also an equal chance
that a Greek natural scientist would
yeah that's a cyclops yeah that's it
look at it that's definitely a
cyclops so you don't know yeah you don't
know yeah there's no way of knowing yeah
there's no reports that I can
remember I looked into this a long time
ago of them ever finding
a skeleton of say like a T-rex or or
[__] some kind of giant Raptor from
the [__] Jurassic Period and them
going I got a skull of a dragon they
never there's no because that would have
been in some
King's [__] Museum and that would
have been handed down for Generations
that would have been a prize thing look
what I killed you know my ancestor
killed that thing it's a dragon you know
that would have survived cuz we still
got Roman statues that survived they
just got handed down in Rich families
yeah so I'm not saying it's impossible
because I'm not I mean you know history
is long uh there have been billions of
people that have lived um it's entirely
possible that somebody came across like
a [__] dinosaur skull or something
and was like holy [__] it's a dragon do
I think that's where all of the Dragon
Stories came from no and um another
thing too like I said I was going to get
into this at the end but it doesn't
really really matter um and a lot of
paleontologists have pointed out it's
like you know it's very very unusual not
impossible it has happen but it's very
unusual for a dinosaur skeleton to be
found
intact um usually like just laying out
in the [__] like I said it has
happened but it's very very rare I mean
fossilization is very rare anyway um so
to find something that still looks like
something that would suggest a dragon to
somebody
um would be not impossible but unlikely
it's mentioned in in an in an ancient
Greek
book that their scientists found the
place where there was a big apocalyptic
battle between Amazon and Griffins from
some tale that they believed in and they
said right where it was they said they
found their bones they said right where
it was the mountain and everything they
went down there to go see what it was
and then a cliff face and it was in a
cliff face they said it was in a cliff
face in in The Cliff face you could see
falling out of there a bunch of fossils
but it wasn't even fossils of
dinosaurs it was mammals [__] like giant
sloth yeah things that they wouldn't
really recommend or recognize and there
was one of these damn animals I don't
remember what it was it's something kind
of like a rhinoceros cross between like
a rhinoceros and a buffalo and if you
look at the side of its skull it does
look like a damn parrot beak kind of
yeah and they were going yeah that's a
and they look at it the body of a lion
and the head of a eagle that's a that's
a [__] Griffin then they would just
find big femur bones of things and go
look at the size of that chick's [__]
leg you know what I mean she's an Amazon
you know it was a big giant woman yeah I
think it was actually gazelle but
they're not finding them whole right
they're finding like you said one bone
at a time it's not impossible but um cuz
they have found you know whole skeletons
like in situ but they don't usually like
usually they're scattered and you have
to kind of dig for them planting seed
says my theory is T-Rex was a giant
chicken technically it bird it was kind
of a bird more birdlike than lizard it's
more bird than lizard which I kind of
feel like finally that's penetrated the
mainstream at this point I'm like
dinosaurs were technically Birds they
were closer to birds than they were to
reptiles I think uh a dragon was a
serpent and then his time goes it's
mentioned in religions and over time it
becomes a sea serpent and it gets bigger
and bigger and bigger just like in and
then it modernizes then it's got
wings I don't can't really explain why
they have them in
China you know but I can explain why the
Egyptians have them the Aztecs had it
but they they had snakes and serpents
yeah theirs is a flying feathered
serpent KET a
kuad there's event more than one of them
I think I think it was a yeah I got a
whole bunch there's a whole bunch of I
mean ketle Kad is the most famous one
but there's there's a bunch of other
Serpentine Dragon like things in there
myology yeah you know yeah I got to hold
this yeah they came from the they
were Cosmic they came from a [__] s
so these are just like religious things
yeah and you know and are we saying are
were they based on real animals probably
but I mean there's some imagination
involved too obviously you know I think
there are like exaggerations or
amalgamations of like stuff that they
saw all the time like I said I kind of
feel like you don't necessarily have
to I mean yeah you have to base stuff on
stuff that you know about that you've
seen because obviously that's kind of
your whole sphere
of of imagination but um but you can
come up with stuff yeah people back then
could just make stuff up it didn't have
to be based on something the an knew
what a Nile crocodile was they were
afraid of them they honored them they
were a Godlike being all right they
protected the Nile and they' eat your
ass they didn't call him a damn dragon
and they didn't have anything to do with
apet they did have a demigod or a God
that was had had an alligator head yeah
soap I think so soek that's what his
name so so that's right so I got a
PE yeah he had a big he had a big yeah
so they knew what an alligator was and
they didn't they don't see an alligator
and call that a dragon or or equate that
to
apep and Romans knew what a what a what
a Nile crocodile
was they didn't call it a
dragon although I don't think I don't
think Romans had the concept of a
dragon I'm trying to
think I can't recall any kind anything
like a
dragon
and the Greeks didn't have anything like
a
dragon that was more near East you know
coming from uh tale of
Marduk and
tmat cosmic space serpent
dragon the Romans and the Greeks may
have had sea serpents
though trying to
think if I recall Jenny would probably
would know from her research she'll be
here in a
second trying to recall if there's any
uh if I remember any Roman
or Greek mentions of a sea
serent I don't think
so no just things like uh
Sirens
uh what else
else
whales if I remember correctly I think
there might have been some references to
Wales we'll see hey Jen did did was
there any Roman references to sea
serpents or Greek references to sea
serpents or dragons or anything like
that I don't think the Romans and Greeks
had anything like that uh Greeks have
lots of dragons they had dragons yeah
I'm going to get into that in a little
oh wait a minute wait a minute yeah the
Hydra yeah they got all hyra yeah that's
right that's right I got a whole section
on that we just haven't got to it yet I
didn't realize that that would be
considered a dragon yeah yeah they got
lots of dragons right like I said I got
a whole section on that okay we're going
to get to it l we're going to get to it
so that's that's right I just was
thinking of dragon in in the western
sense of a dragon or the medieval sense
of a dragon yeah and like I said the
modern conception of a dragon that's
just from the Middle Ages right there
was like way
snake that had legs or wings or whatever
and like a lot of them I think the old
ones like now obviously like dragons
people think of them like breathing fire
and stuff which some of them did back in
the day but I think prior to the Middle
Ages a lot of them actually spit poison
yeah that was a pretty common thing for
them to do yeah yeah the Hydra would
have been a dragon Yeah well yeah and
there was there was a lot of other ones
there was other ones I'm trying to think
of that yeah yeah like I said we'll get
into that in a little bit so let's talk
about the eastern dragons for a little
while because as far as I
know um China in particular has one of
the
longest um kind of oral traditions of
dragons but they have like a slightly
different conception of it than we do in
the west obviously um they actually
call they actually call what we would
call a dragon they call it um loong I
guess I'm not really sure if that's how
you pronounce it correctly and they're
usually seen as a good thing um usually
it's good luck um and a lot of kind of
um deities from East Asia and demigods
and things like that have um they either
ride on dragons or have dragons as you
know companions like their buddies or
whatever and also uh whoever the Emperor
of China was at the time they were also
a associated with Dragons which was like
a really positive like sign of their
like power and wisdom and everything
like
that and so for a time um whoever was
the emperor of China like he was the
only person allowed to have like dragons
on his stuff you know what I mean like
on his clothes and everything now they
also have like in the Chinese
Zodiac um there is a dragon on there and
that's like the kind of highest or most
sought after
um zodiac sign so I was watching a
documentary not too long um just like
before we the show started and she was
saying that whenever it's the Year of
the Dragon there's always like a whole
bunch of like there's more births than
usual because everybody tries to like
have their kids in the year of the
dragon because it's supposed to be like
super lucky it's like the best one you
know what I mean which I thought that
was really
funny now there's also a lot of stories
in China like I said it's not so much
they don't have a lot of stories about
defeating dragons but they have a lot of
stories
about um like raising dragons which I
always thought was kind of interesting
like one of the most famous ones um
which was maybe came about during the
Waring States period there's a man named
dong Fu and he just loves dragons and
kind of has insight into their
personalities or whatever and he's able
to like tame them so like the emperor
gives him a name that means Dragon Riser
you know what I mean so there's a lot of
stories like that with people raising
dragons rather than like defeating them
also I thought this was kind of a cool
story as well so there's uh a story
about a guy named
fui and he's supposedly like Crossing
this River and he sees a Chinese dragon
what they call a horse dragon cuz it
kind of has a horse head sort of and it
has like all these dots like on its face
and on its back and you know on its side
and everything like that like all this
patterns of dots and he thought this was
so cool that when he goes home he draws
a picture of the Dragon like with all
the dots on it and then he used the dots
later on to invent Chinese writing so
even the written Chinese language is
attributed to a dragon which like I said
I thought was like pretty cool
somebody's asking me Danny's ask me what
weapon would I select to kill a dragon I
was selecting
m47 m47 Dragon Wire guided missile and
I'm qualified to use it it's a old
missile from the [__] 70s but that's
what I would use it would kill it you
could have kill a dragon with a missile
[__] right carry around yeah it's a
man portable missile I would try to make
friends with a dragon maybe he's cool
and he ask what I would use to kill the
dragon I said I would then I could fly
around I would use one that I'm
qualified to use
about it get an m47 Dragon Wire guided
missile put the day tracker on it that
[__] extend the bipods and [__]
launched that [__] and
[__] killed a dragon with it had a
five pound [__] shape charge Warhead
on the end of it about size of a coffee
can it it would kill a [__] Dragon
yeah hi Pokey I think that [__] blew
like a 17 17 in s it would go through
like 17 inches of solid steel and
Warhead so it it'd kill a
dragon oracles looking for imagination
exaggerations please see the stories of
prester John oh yeah I remember that
story I remember reading that when I was
younger yeah prester John was a
legendary Christian ruler of the East
emphasis on legendary supposedly he had
unicorns yeah um I remember reading
about that in like a one of those like
weird stories books like when I was a
kid we should probably you know what we
should do a show about that because I
always thought that was like a really
interesting what's a show prester John I
don't know that one yeah he's like a
mythological like Christian
figure it's pretty interesting actually
I like to do some of the American
mythology like [__] Paul bunan and
[__] oh we never did one like that
myology that's another one that we
should do who was the black dude that
John Henry John Henry is that the guy
who [__] um could could beat the
steam sh
steam drill that was the first African
Aman superhero yeah John
Henry I don't think it was based in
anything real though probably not but um
but yeah cuz the United States has their
own like folklore our own we have our
own little F and we should do like yeah
and we learned about that in school like
Paul bunion and John Henry and all that
kind of stuff John Henry that's right
yeah learned about him in school back
back in the day yeah he was in a race
against the damn steam drill steam drill
who could [__] tunnel through the
mountain to put the railroad in there
yeah and he was this big ass [__]
Alpha [__] black dude and he beat
that steam drill but it killed him yeah
he died completely he's like I Won
godamn Won I won he died of a it was
just it was just a tale of [__] man
against
machine yeah Oracle said there's a
children's book where Paul bunion and
John Henry played a baseball game
together it's pretty
cute yeah I used to love all those like
what cuz like I said we did a whole like
when I was in elementary school probably
we did like a whole um little section of
like all that American folklore Johnny
apple seed yeah like all that kind of
stuff and I always thought that was like
so interesting I think he was a real guy
though I think what he was sort of kind
of based on a real dude I mean but like
I said it's kind of legendary but I
think he's sort of kind of got the
darker side we already talked about that
[__] Jeremiah [__] Johnson
well yeah yeah kill [__] with
another [__] did all kinds of
[__] yeah or at least his leg anyway
yeah right yeah he was at war with the
Crow Indians for killing his fcking
Flathead wife who was another Indian
it's it's a story of a mountain man
white man mountain man gone engine
that's what they called it back in the
day that's when you became an idiot we
did a show about him didn't we did a
show about him yeah I thought we did
liver liver eatting Johnson he was
cannibal called him yeah he'd eat the
liers out of Crow Indian just cuz you
made him mad yeah he was the boogeyman
for the crow they were scared of him but
when he by the time he got old by the
time he got
old all the crow had died off and fought
fought him and it was all the kids that
grew up were scared of him right he's
like a boogeyman they adopted him they
made him a they made him a they
respected him and that was a real dude
but I think a lot of the stories about
it were made they made a lot of stories
yeah but that's you know that kind of
happens when like he was a real person
but a lot of [__] that they attribute to
him probably did that yeah he was he had
a oneman war against the Crow Indian
yeah he was he was mad he pissed off
yeah I guess so um but yeah so uh they
had a [__] Robert refer movie called
[__] Jeremiah Johnson yeah that's a
good movie it's pretty good movie yeah
pretty good movie it's it's epic the
screenplay was written by uh [__] uh
John millius who did Conan and uh John
millius also did uh Apocalypse Now or
think did just no yeah he directed
Apocalypse Now didn't he no no he just
wrote the screenplay I think right maybe
I'd have to look it up yeah I don't know
if you're right about that but he
definitely didn't direct it Francis for
Copa directed it but I think John milus
was involved in that
yeah um but yeah so where was I okay so
uh so yeah so dragon's responsible for
uh Chinese writing or at least so the
story goes um also a lot of like Heroes
of Chinese mythology um are said to be
like demigods in the sense that their
moms had sex with Dragons so they're
like half dragon and I think there's
kind of a thing too where the
Chinese um said their ancestors were
dragons you know what I mean so like I
said dragons are seen as a good thing um
also there's a story from Southwest
China that a Heavenly Dragon actually
made the first humans by like a bunch of
monkeys came into his cave and he
breathed on them and it made them humans
and then then they went out and
propagated you know what I mean so I
thought that was like kind of cool so
like I said they really it's almost like
they trace their ancestry back to
dragons which I think is like really
interesting Danny said that [__]
Leonard Lake was all about
unicorns was said he dressed a goat up
as a unicorn I didn't know about that
did we did a show about them a long time
ago but
that's the guy with Charles Yang the D
were doing yeah those [__] sick
those I have to go back and like see if
we mentioned that on our show or not cuz
that was remember time ago I don't
remember that either never heard that
either but um but yeah so much like I
don't know I kind of feel like this is
pretty Universal across
Asia but dragons are associated with
rain and are supposed to have power over
rain um so when it doesn't rain
um that means that dragons are being
lazy which I thought was very funny yeah
yeah so it's like so like Villages if
it's if there's a drought like they'll
have like a festival or like a ritual
where they ask the dragons to make it
rain because they're the ones that Make
It Rain you know what I mean so like a
lot of the gods are like rain rain gods
like the dragons are rain gods and so
there's like temples to them and [__]
like that which is pretty cool so um
similarly there are also dragons in a
lot of Mythology like Korea and they're
pretty similar to the Chinese ones I
think their beards are a little bit
longer um but much like the Chinese ones
they also have uh numerology is kind of
ties in with it as well so um just like
in China also in Korea they have like
nine is like kind of a lucky number so
dragons have 81 scales on their backs
which is nine time n right and that's
kind of supposed to represent uh Yang
you know what I mean um and generally in
Korea just like in China um dragons are
generally um good guys they're generally
like benevolent they're usually related
to water uh farming stuff like that uh
they bring rain which is generally a
good thing because it grows your crops
and and so dragons in Korea just like in
China like live in lakes and seas and
stuff like that like every time there's
a big lake or something it has like a
like a dragon that lives in it that you
kind of like rever or whatever you been
able to find anything about where the
origin of these stories came from in in
China and you know like what are they
talking about talking about serpent
flying
serpents well a lot of like I said the
ones they don't generally in Asia um
they're water related okay so I don't
know um if they're talking about an
actual animal yeah like a whale or an
orish or an eel or something like that
or if it's just I don't I don't really
know but it does seem like across Asia
dragons are almost
universally connected to water and Rain
like anytime you have like a lake or a
sea or anything like that it's supposed
to have like pretty much like a a dragon
that lives in it and you can like ask it
for things I guarantee you it's an e it
may be um that may be what they're
talking about because a lot of stuff
like a what was that Japanese thing was
actually a salamander what they were
talking about mhm what was that thing
called Kaa AAA AAA yeah which was a
mythological creature that killed
children it was and it really existed it
was yeah it's a real animal the Japanese
giant salamander it's the size of a man
it's big yeah I've seen pictures of them
yeah and it could bite a child and drown
it pull it underneath the water drown it
so it was a mythological creature that
actually existed but you know they also
said they were could talk and they could
do things they're mischievous which that
would be something but they're talking
about they're talking about a giant
Japanese salamander they're endangered
now oh and it's the size of a small man
yeah they're pretty large yeah a big
[__] head big shovel size saw like a
photo or like a video of one I it was
alarming I didn't actually know that
salamor that large existed size the
midsize alligator yeah they're very big
yeah they're very big I can see how that
would like pretty be pretty alarming if
you didn't know what that was so maybe
they're seeing a pretty big eels and
they're seeing they bigger ones down
there when they can talk they can cause
the rain maybe they're talking about
eels yeah and they're staying eels and
their because that's that was common in
their diet yeah so they're imagining
that there's a even bigger eel down
there with powers yeah CU I'm thinking
like whatever the Eastern conception of
a dragon was it had to have something to
do with like a sea creature because
almost all of them are associated with
water and bodies of water all of bodies
of water have like a dragon associated
with it but the dragons are good guys
they're not like evil they're never
shown with wings or anything but in the
sky a lot of times in the tapestry
they're in the sky with clouds behind
them they're flying yeah they're usually
very snake like they a lot of them have
legs like four legs but they don't have
wings in the same way that the Western
on right they have legs yeah they
generally do have legs it might be a
salamander possibly like another giant
salamander that's extinct now that was
in China like I said they might be
talking about yeah an extinct animal or
they're just exaggerating an animal that
they see all the time that's what I'm
thinking they're exaggerating an animal
they used to see all the time probably
something like a giant Japanese Sal
Salander but they probably had in China
yeah big ass salamander the size of an
alligator that would be impressive yeah
you could in your mind go there bigger
ones you just don't see them they're
deeper and they fly and then you you
build on the on that Legend yeah oh they
taught us how to write and what's weird
is that if it is a salamander they are
if you look at the giant J Japanese
salamander there's something kind of
manlike about it the Japanese describe
it as manlike it has fingers and [__]
yeah and in the Chinese dragon the
fingers are [__] Paramount that's
holding orbs and spheres and how many
yeah pearl of wisdom is is a big thing
the dragons are always like holding the
pearl of wisdom they do that in Korea
you our dragons are more like based on
[__] we see like
lizards yeah that's the medieval dragon
is more like a
lizard Chinese and Oriental dragons
might be based
on Kappa or Salam Ander giant
salamanders how much you bet yeah maybe
or like I said maybe eels or or like I
said could be I don't know um what the
range of an orish is yeah have you ever
seen an orish they're long yeah cuz some
of them get Hella big yeah that's sea
that's sea creature though yeah I think
this is something they're seeing in
fresh water maybe they're Farmers that
kind of checks out that it would be
salamander you and in the
Chinese depictions it has a man like a
lion some salamanders have gills yeah
come exterior it kind of looks like a
main yeah so they may be exaggerating
something that they're seeing yeah it
could be that you know or they're
hearing about
it farmers are talking about it and then
people in the city exaggerated in their
mind and then they they're writing
Dragon
Stories these stories and these little
tapestries and [__] that they're making
don't come from Villages it's in there
cities so they're not really living the
same life as a country person who may be
seeing these things they just might be
hearing about them they might be six
feet long you know but then the more you
tell it more you tell it they're bigger
and then as the generations go on they
get bigger and bigger bigger yeah so you
got a guy in the city talking about oh
yeah they're [__] 30 feet long and
then like 100 years later no no no no no
they're 100 feet long that's how big my
dragon is got a whole man it's got three
five figures on it like a man
claws I think they're talking about a
salamander yeah maybe so I'd have to do
some research and see if China had those
salamanders I know that they were doing
things like growing rice yeah there
bodies of water everywhere and they come
out of the
water sounds like salamander and Erica
said I bet those sea creatures were a
lot bigger back in the day as well
that's another thing that's another
thing and we've talked about that before
like when we talked about like um sea
monsters and stuff like that it's like I
don't think those people were crazyer
seeing things necessarily but it could
be that animals were bigger back then
because we didn't have like over fishing
and all that kind of stuff so it wasn't
it wasn't industrial fishing right so
animals could have been much larger yeah
they could have got lot larger because
they lived longer and there was more
food so they ate more and got bigger
yeah there was wood Cuts medieval wood
cuts from Europe showing the the Harvest
of that year and it would show you know
a cow and a big pile of corn and then
next to the cow a catfish the same size
as the cow and people thought well
they're just trying to depict a catfish
no [__] Jeremy Wade [__] proved
that a catfish if it's old enough can be
about as big as a cow he's caught some
cat almost that almost that big yeah and
that's you know and I'm sure they were
much bigger back in the day yeah
medievals didn't have [__] rod and
reel they caught everything through Nets
and once once a fish got too big for a
net you couldn't catch it so it would
just live for a long time
so that fish might be 100 years old or
150 years old and it's got [__] big
you know and there was accounts medieval
accounts of guys being eaten by these
lake monsters that's probably what it is
Catfish because they can swallow a man
well and every now and then they still
kill people yeah like catfish do yeah
because they're some of them are
absolutely big enough to like drag
somebody under water right and they
weren't catching cows siiz catfish with
Nets and Rod and real they were catching
it by draining the pond drain the
pond sitting there on fing get him what
happened in my house yeah yeah it's
probably how they were that's how they
were catch them I was living in that you
[__] they would drain ponds and
just [__] get every fish out of the
damn Pond which seems like cheating they
didn't care back then they were
medievals no of course not yeah then
they'd let the pond fill back up still
cheating they're like we don't care we
just want to eat yeah but yeah I might
need another drink on your way back
okay almost
empty but yeah so um yeah so a lot of
the Asian um dragon stories are like
pretty similar another thing that
there's a lot of stories about in Korea
is stories about people going to the
like the undersea Kingdom of the dragon
king that's like a pretty common Trope
uh in a lot of like myths in
Korea um in like fashion Japanese dragon
myths very very similar um dragons tend
to look pretty similar they usually have
three claws rather than you know Chinese
they they the Chinese Legends seem to
have like kind of a little bit of a
hierarchy where they have like three CLA
one dragons which are like you know
pretty cool but then like the four Cloud
ones are like pretty really cool and
then like the five Cloud ones ooh that's
like the emperor [__] right there so but
the Japanese ones tend to have three
claws but just like in China and Korea
in Japan uh dragons almost universally
associated with uh bodies of water lakes
and stuff and also with rainfall um also
they tend not to have wings and kind of
look snake like um there's kind of
another thing too where they can be if
you wanted to get rid of them you could
actually
exercise them with metal like a sword or
something like that um so but like I
said they very very similar otherwise
now India also has its own dragon kind
of
stories um the uh one of the one of the
oldest kind of written records or
whatever uh mythology the
rigveda there is um and this is kind of
interesting because this is very very
much like a western dragon story because
you have Indra who is a storm God right
and he fights against a big giant
serpent serpent called vertra which like
I said that's a very Western thing but
that's from
India um so it's basically and the and
the dragon in this story actually
represents not rainfall but the opposite
drought so it's almost kind of like an
inversion it's weird because it's like a
western story but it's like an inversion
of the Asian story too because usually
dragons are good because they bring rain
but this one is like no I bring drought
like it's opposite so we have to have
it's almost like an in between kind of
story which I thought was kind of
interesting um but Indra the storm God
does actually kill the dragon using his
Thunderbolt um so when he kills the
dragon then it can rain you know what I
mean so I thought that was kind of
interesting cuz that's like an inversion
um Vietnam also has Dragon Stories um
and again very similar to other Asian
ones where it's like a positive thing
it's usually associated with like
deities and royalty and things of that
nature um and is usually seen as like um
having to do with like uh creation you
know what I mean so it's so it's a
positive uh connotation whereas it's
usually negative in Western uh
mythology so as I mentioned earlier and
as I was just mentioning when we were
talking about the Indian
story you have particularly in the
induran tradition uh you have tons and
tons and tons of stories of Heroes
demigods storm Gods Thunder Gods
fighting dragons or giant serpents
there's tons and tons of those stories
in the Indo European
tradition um in almost every version of
these stories the dragon has a bunch of
heads that's very common or has a a
bunch of other things like a bunch of
Tails or something like that um and in
almost every story as in the Asian
stories uh the dragons are usually
associated with water in some way like
it came out of the sea or It's
associated with a lake or something like
that so you were talking about ancient
Greece before so let's kind of talk
about ancient Greece a little bit
because they have a lot of dragon
stories
so the first mention of a dragon what we
recognize as a dragon in ancient Greece
is from The
Iliad and the first mention of that word
is when they say that
Agamemnon has a blue dragon on his uh
sword thing like his belt that has a
sword in it and also has like a
breastplate with a three-headed dragon
on it I forgot about that yeah Aon had
dragons on his on his [__] yeah and
that's like the first written you know
and and like I said a lot of these came
from like oral tradition I guess what
dragon mean to the Greeks like I said it
meant serpent it me Serpent serpent um
the word dragon or draon in Greek just
means it me Serpent huge serpent
basically what it means they're talking
about the uh serpent in the
constellations CU some of they're cut
like Draco yeah that's the Latin word
and it means the same thing serpent
right so there was a Greek poem called
the theogony I guess is how you
pronounce it which was written by uh
hessi in the 7th Century
BCE and in that poem Zeus fights a
monster named Typhon who has 100 heads
it's like a dragon with 100 snake heads
and the heads breathe fire so it's very
early like dragon okay yeah it's like
it's like Hydra but the heads don't
multiply right yeah we'll get into that
in a little bit too all right but so
basically Zeus so he fights Typhon and
he uses his Thunderbolts and he like
kills he burns all the heads and then
takes Typhon and throws him into
Tartarus is I guess you pronounce it's
like the Greek version of Hell
basically um so it's a multi-headed
snake yeah it's basically and in some
versions it has wings too so very so
very Dragon they get European on us yeah
yeah yeah well but pre that like this is
very old this is real this is ancient
Greek [__] could could be it could be
that the uh medievals got that from
Reading GRE Greek mythology I'm sure
they probably they read that they had
access to it yeah that right that came
along which later so it might be that
hey you know the wyvern has is a worm
which means Serpent and it has wings and
that's how they drew it so probably got
that from great mythology yeah it's like
it doesn't have wings in all the
versions but in some versions it does
but it breathes fire for sure and it has
like a whole bunch of heads and it's
basic it's like a yeah it has a bunch of
snake heads that's basically what it is
um there's also a story about
Apollo who fights a dragon or like a
giant serpent named python okay um who's
been kind of [__] [__] up around Deli
yeah you got to sometimes yeah and so he
kills the Dragon with poison arrows so
that's another story as well just
described as a big snake yeah pretty
much like a big giant snake which that's
where the the that's where it got its
name python you saw a big snake called
it python yeah yeah which like I said
see this [__] fasinating it's F very
fitting look at that thing what kind of
snake we call that we call it python
[__] that's where they got out of the
old stories right out of the old stories
from from Greece yeah um also as Tom
mentioned earlier Heracles or Hercules
if you prefer Jesus yeah as the second
of his 12 Labors he has to kill the
Hydra which is essentially a dragon I
mean it's a big snake that has a whole
bunch of heads yeah every time you cut a
head off it grows two back and and it
grows two back so he had to figure out
how to do that the heads of multiply
yeah which um that's yeah that's they
upped that they upped
Typhon likeon but worse but worse every
time you it doesn't have aund heads
every time you cut one off it grows two
back so it's like you're just working
against yourself what are you going to
do Hercules yeah um but yeah so this so
the Hydra lived in a swamp obviously uh
in LNA um now the name Hydra actually
means water snake uh that's what it
means in Greek now there's different
versions of the Hydra
story um they can't really decide like
what weapon that Heracles used to kill
it but by the time the story had kind of
evolved they're like well what he
probably did was that he cut the heads
off and then cauterized them burn so
they wouldn't grow back however here's
another little snag one of hydra's heads
was Immortal so that one you couldn't do
so he had this cracks me up so he had to
cut that one off and then he like buried
it and put like a big ass rock on top of
it and I said so what happens to the
next person that comes along and lifts
that rock up they're going to get a real
good big surprise aren't they well what
they did is they these are like movies
of the day they set it up for a sequel
they set it up for a sequel yeah
somebody comes along and be like hey
what's this oh [__] they might have to
bring Hydra back kind of like bringing
back the T the Terminator or something
you might have to bring HRA yeah see
they were think they were thinking ahead
because it sounds like Hydra is a
[__] reboot of [__] uh what was
the other one tyon Typhon with 100 heads
yeah they just they just [__]
rebooted it and made it better yeah it
was a
sequel It's like he doesn't have as many
heads but they just grow back if you cut
it's kind of like the first Terminator
and then the liquid metal
Terminator that's what they did that's
right that's a very yeah that's they
knew what they were doing they knew what
they were doing even back
then they had they had fans geeking out
over this [__] trying to figure out what
was [__] you know Canon What's Cannon
and what is [__] fan fish
they were nerds back then too oh no no
no that's Disney that's Disney that's
not Star Wars they're doing that kind of
[__] yeah yeah yeah cuz people are no
different yeah they they called them
they just had different media they had
different do it they were doing the same
thing they're arguing about the [__]
story just like people argue about [__]
nowadays oh yeah [__] and the
Egyptians had Catwoman sexy Catwoman
they're [__] bastad cat goddess
that's Catwoman
literally so nothing really new yeah
we've we even we are rebooting it all
those Marvel heroes and [__] that's Star
Wars even that's Indian stories that are
kind of like Star Wars everybody gets
ideas from other places that's just kind
of how and like I said human brains are
all like essentially pretty similar and
all kind of travel in the same channels
so it's just kind of like so you're
going to get similar [__] like even if
you didn't yeah even if you didn't
directly rip another story off there's
only so many possibilities that your
brain can come up there are ancient
Indian stories about heroes and flying
machines in the sky that can throw
lightning and fire and [__] it's Flash
Gordon yeah that's what they're talking
about well yeah basically it's Proto
flash Gord Proto Flash Gordon yeah which
that's where Star Wars came from yeah
well okay so and Heracles not only had
to kill the [__] Hydra for a second
lady labor but for his 11th labor he had
to fight another [__] Dragon because
if you remember he had to go get a
golden apple from that tree in the
garden of the Hesperides and that Garden
was uh guarded by yet another Dragon
like a big ass [__] snake called
Leon that never slept like I said its
eyes were always open like I mentioned
earlier um now Leon in some versions of
the story he has like a whole bunch of
heads and in some just has like one head
you know what I mean so he's but he's
technically a dragon um now in earlier
versions of the story leadon is actually
Immortal but later versions of the story
um specifically ones written by ureides
and Sophocles say that um that Heracles
killed him um and then later on um you
later again they said oh Heracles like
clubbed him to death you know what I
mean um and also there's another later
version that said that he actually took
the blood of the Hydra and dipped his
arrows in it and killed late on with
that yeah I remember that sword yeah
yeah yeah so that was yet another so
Heracles had to fight like a whole bunch
of dragons like there's that herac knew
his [__] man he was the he was the
original hero or [__] he was a badass
hero he was yeah they made [__] even C
so B de made some good movies based on
that from Clash of the Titans even
though that was Perseus but there were
that same kind of stuff there were a
bunch of Love Clash of the Titans yeah I
never get sick of that movie there were
Hercules movies too they weren't kind of
good as [__] was well there's a bunch
of Hercules movies the Italians made a
bunch of them like their us one stuff
but like there was a bunch of them on
MST so I saw a bunch of them and they're
some of them were kind of terrible but I
like the Sinbad movies and like Hercules
versus the moonmen I could have done
without that one yeah stupid I
like I liked [__]
uh the [__] Sinbad movies I did like
those too and and I liked the [__] uh
Clash of the Titans that the original
the old one that was pretty good I love
able unleashing the the Kraken on that
one man at least the Kraken I saw that
Clash of the Titans that came out in 81
and it was on HBO or Cinemax like every
two hours it seemed like it was just
every time it was on I watched it yeah
so I've seen it like four million times
watch Percy's fighting that [__]
two-headed [__] seirus was that with
that dog cus cus and then he had three
heads he had three heads that's right
and then it had the uh the Medusa and
that that was I think that was Ray Harry
House's last movie like I love the
Medusa in that I just I love the
mechanical owl that was there to Bo yeah
Bo he was there to [__] compete with
RTD2 yeah they had to put that kind of
[__] in there but you know what I mean I
didn't mind that it was okay and the big
they had the big ass scorpions and like
but actually one of the like Medusa is
the coolest in that but but my favorite
I think other than Medusa was calabos
yeah that final final boss fight with
calabos that was good yeah he was super
cool like and he kept making like
Andromeda come there and like solve all
those riddles and [__] like that I love
that everybody was good-looking in the
movie yeah a lot of hotties and [__]
yeah yeah I love that [__] movie I
could watch it again right now yeah I
wouldn't mind seeing it again I would I
actually would mind I think we reviewed
it not too long ago but yeah I love that
[__]
movie um so yeah other than Heracles or
Hercules if you prefer also had uh Jason
of uh and the argonut fame he also
fought a dragon another good movie
because he had to go get the Golden
Fleece right yeah now the Golden Fleece
was like hanging on that tree tree yeah
and the tree was guarded by a big ass
serpent okay um and this serpent is
described as being in breath and length
a 50 or ship so a big [__] it's like
a dragon yeah so it's a dragon it's a
dragon so there's a bunch of different
versions of this story as well in one
version of the story Jason kills the
dragon and just is like doink and like
takes the Golden Fleece and takes off
with media right um now there's also
another version where he didn't even
wake up the dragon he just kind of was
like do bye and like took off like
without waking it up and look without
killing it which seems a little cowardly
but okay it Dawns on me now that in
mil's version of Conan when Conan jumps
down to the temple is set to go get the
remember the the the eye with the eye of
the serpent uhhuh he fights that giant
anaconda yeah he's basically killing a
dragon yeah he's slaying a dragon to get
see you see it all makes sense all makes
sense it all makes sense now yeah it
makes sense now the Greeks would have
called that a draco like I said this is
a very very common yeah there are so
many I had to take out so many stories
you guys like I went through it's like
there's I was just like there's too many
I just have to like [__] cuz there's
a million and a lot of them are like
really similar but so yeah so Jason in
some versions he kills the snake which
okay badass but in some versions he's
like you know what I'm just gonna and he
just like like you know what I mean Just
sh I'm not GNA wake him up I'm just I'm
just gonna take it um so he does that
also in some versions media and this
happened in Ides is play media too which
is awesome if you haven't read it I read
it in school and it's really really good
um she said that she killed the dragon
like by poisoning it or like knocked it
out so Jason could steal the [__] she's
like yeah that was all me you know what
I mean so there's that version too which
I I actually kind of like that version
also since we're talking about uh
ancient Greece let's talk about um the
founding myth of Thieves this is pretty
this is a weird this is a wild [__]
story story it's a wild
story so there's this dude named Cadmus
and he's a a prince a Phoenician
Prince and Apollo tells him cuz but this
is how Apollo do I guess so he's like
okay you follow this heer this cow and
wherever it lays down you found a city
there which
okay all right Apollo what whatever so
they did what he said Apollo is a God
okay so you got to do whatever he says
so Cadmus gets all his dudes his his men
or whatever and they follow the
heer so the heer lays down and Cadmus is
like okay um I didn't know this was part
of the deal but they're like okay well
all of you guys go find a spring because
I have to sacrifice this heer now to
Athena because apparently that's a thing
that you have to do so the guys are like
okay chief we're going to go find the
spring cuz you have to sacrifice by a
spring that's the
rules so the dudes all go off and they
find a
spring so he can do the
sacrifice however the spring was guarded
by a dragon which apparently the god
Aries had put there because that was his
special spring I guess and he was just
kind of like I I don't want anybody
[__] with my spring I'm going to put
this big ass Dragon here to make sure
nobody [__] with it I don't want
anybody swimming in it it's mine so
that's what happened so all the dudes go
over there and it's like well we found
it spring but there's a [__] Dragon
there and the dragon ate them all the
dudes so Cadmus is a little uh put out
by this
situation and he's like you killed all
my dudes and so he kills the
Dragon now Athena comes to him and says
for some reason hey now that the
dragon's dead why don't you tear all its
teeth out and plant them like you would
seeds yeah so Cadmus is like sounds like
a plan so he does that and out of where
the teeth are
planted like Warriors grow yeah demons
or skeletons in the movie they're called
well no but they're called sparto sparto
is what they're called it's which means
sewn men like sewn as imp
planted so they grew out of there for
whatever reason I don't really know I
don't really know why why Athena said
like why to do this but but then like so
all of these Warriors gr out of the
earth like from the
teeth and then Cadmus decides I'm going
to [__] with these people so he starts
throwing rocks in the middle of all the
Warriors and they start start thinking
each other is throwing rocks at them so
they start fighting each fighting each
other okay which okay doesn't make any
sense so they all kill each other until
like only a few of them are left which
doesn't make any sense to me but okay
that's I was I thought this sounded like
I said this is a wild story it sounds
very familiar I thought maybe that was
they had a ray hariry Howen version of
this wasn't wasn't some of the teeth of
a dragon used grown like didn't
they didn't it grow some demons in one
of them that might have been another
variation well from the well was that
Jason and the argonut Jason the Argon
sound something came from that but uh
yeah this this goes back to what I said
earlier some of the
Roman stuff and Greek stuff the stories
are religious in nature but you don't
understand what morality they're
teaching right and
when that little tale about getting them
to fight each other because they grew
from the dragon's teeth made sense to
them because there's more to that story
that we but I'm sit there going yeah
what was the point of that there's a
point to it I'm sure there is it's
referring to something else they
believed in and we don't have that yeah
um that exists a lot in Roman religious
mythology like in one of them I forgot
remember the damn girl's name it might
have been Daphne or something or one of
the one of the Roman goddesses she's
running from another God or you know l
her God who grabs her to try to sexually
assault her and she to get to get away
to get away from him she turns into a
tree and she never turns back again and
we don't know
what what that story meant here's the
thing did she turn herself into a tree
thinking she'd be able to turn back into
a person or she's like well this is my
one trick nobody knows I'm going to use
it up right now it's like well now I'm
[__] now I'm a tree I thought
yeah last I heard of it nobody really
knew what the story meant better than
getting I don't remember what Goddess it
was was it
dapne Cil some Bullit I can't remember
like yeah I know what you're talking
about yeah but I can't remember it's a
very small story it's Roman it's a very
short story it's Roman it's it's part of
a larger story if I remember
correctly but nobody really knew knows
what value was trying to teach closest I
can think of it was they're just trying
to say that she was
so pure
that she would rather rather be a tree
right than than that sense to to be
defiled that was the idea cuz that's a
pretty common Trope in that's prob all
that meant yeah like she would rather
just be a [__] tree a tree than to
take that dick sure and the dude who did
it was a hero in another story if I
remember correctly he wasn't a bad guy
just he he couldn't control himself she
was so beautiful that that type of deal
that's what they all say yeah well I I
guess passion would run away with the
Roman man man or the Roman God
definitely so you know what I mean they
just they could control it yeah they had
uh they had different uh yeah views on
things I guess I'm just like you do that
to people it's you're not a good guy I
don't yeah but she was in public though
I don't care what else she was in public
should have been wearing that wearing
that dress right you know you shouldn't
have been like existing walking around
Prett what are you thinking you're damn
too damn pretty dressed like that come
you can't walk around going to happen
come on yeah that's that that was the
thinking
yeah well and sadly some people still
feel I still like that in some countries
it is yeah yeah so uh so yeah should
have stayed home under your father's
protection that's thing yeah you can't
ever go outside no you're you're a
priser everyone's like you know dicks
will just be like flying at you jump up
and jump in you that's all there's never
can't tell never can't tell it's not
their fault they they can't help it most
of the dudes like that have never had a
ass beating though that's the problem
well they they clearly need
one but you know what I mean maybe
they'll have a few and they'll learn but
um but you know so yeah so here's this
okay so this whole story like I said
this is a crazy story and it doesn't
make any sense to me so all of these
Warriors grow out of the teeth out the
dragon teeth and then Cadmus is like ha
and he [__] with them and like makes
them all kill each other well not all of
them there's like a few of them left
still but I don't know what happens to
them after that so then Aries who owned
the dragon who is protecting the spring
is mad because Cadmus killed his Dragon
because that's kind of [__] up right
so Cadmus had to be ares's slave for
eight years I don't know what that
entailed um you know I'm imagining all
kinds of things but it's like it could
just be like hey go get me a beer from
the fridge or it could have been you
know B over Z Zach's here he shows up
Tammy's teasing him yeah
yeah you missed it Jenny Peg Tom guess
you won't leave again now will you yeah
yeah I know you totally missed it missed
it dude we did it on YouTube got paid
too got a new Harley on way what yeah
there you go he just ordered it like
right after it happened yeah right after
have one of one of these days we'll have
some millionaire that's really into our
show yeah and we'll pay that amount of
money got that new sports to s coming
and then you'll be sorry because you're
going to have to let me do it then cuz
you said ain't never going to happen you
said then all of a sudden some Saudi oil
Baron comes up goes oh that's nothing
yeah sure yeah [__] I want this video
on my desk [__]
tomorrow well I mean if if we just had
to send him a video we could do that we
could do that look at her she's trying
to [__] sell my ass to [__] man stop
hey you were trying to sell my ass you
said if some if some like billionaire
from the Middle East was going to give
me a qu million dollars to go spend a
week on some yacht he's like yeah I'm
going to pack your bags you better
go I was like so yeah same goes for you
buddy it's all in good fun not just me
it's all in good fun it's uh it's got to
be fair I'm not you got to do same [__]
I got to do that's how that works I'm
just
saying oh man you know you would come on
man um so yeah so he got to be ar slave
for 8 years I don't know what that
entailed like I said I'm imagining all
kinds of dirty [__] but yeah now at the
end of the8 years though he was able to
marry uh the daughter of Aries and
Aphrodite who was named harmonia
lovely and so then Cadmus and harmonia
moved to this place called IA where they
got to be king and queen and then they
also got transformed into dragons cuz
his
reasons the end oh yeah and I was just
like I wonder what that means what
yeah what I mean ancient Greece you
crazy you crazy that's a crazy story
they hadn't figured out the art of the
screen play some although not goingon to
lie I would watch a movie without plot
it doesn't make any sense yeah but you
know what's funny is that a lot of the
Greek plays it has survived are real
good but there's something about their
religious lore their mythology well like
I said I we're calling it mythology but
for them it was religious lore it did a
lot of it didn't make sense the Romans
were the same
way I um well I read in school like we
did a whole thing about um ancient Greek
like you know ureides and all that kind
of stuff and I actually read a few plays
from back then and a lot of them were
good yeah a lot of them were good like
like I said the Ides play media is
excellent I have it somewhere that's a
great [__] play I mean they still do
performances of it
nowadays so but like I said a lot of
their stories there's a lot of different
versions of it and it's just like we've
lost a lot of the context it doesn't
think some of that religious stuff
had expanded universe stuff that we
don't have sure yeah well that think
there's a lot more to it we don't know
yeah because well like I said we don't
really have the context so it's like
they might have known all of this other
cultural [__] that we don't that's been
lost since then other stories answered
stuff right probably all interlock and
everybody's like oh yeah we know this
character we know that character we know
this story so it's probably a situation
calling back it's calling back and
there's probably Easter eggs and [__] in
it we we would we wouldn't know
yeah that's kind of what I'm thinking
yeah so so yeah um and we mentioned
earlier but later on in the New
Testament um Book of Revelation
obviously mentions a great red dragon as
well uh that has a whole bunch of heads
seven heads 10 horns seven crowns all of
that oh that's the horor Babylon Dragon
yeah yeah yeah the dragon yeah even
though that's there that's describing
Rome yeah but they describe it in in the
terms of a dragon which I thought was
interesting which might be reflecting
back on the Leviathan yeah image from
the Old Testament they're saying the
city of Rome is a bad [__] place mhm
uh the heads and the horns represented
Emperors is it's placing it in time
during the time of Nero is what it's
talking about
yeah so let's talk a little bit about
Norse
mythology uh because there are a lot of
dragons in Norse mythology as well um
coming from Denmark Iceland uh Norway
all of those kind of places so um there
was a story probably the most the best
known one there's a dragon named faer
yeah and he he was killed by a guy named
sigard now what happened in this story
and it'll probably sound really familiar
to you if you're familiar with the plot
of Lord of the Rings because this is
kind of where jro or tolken maybe got
the idea from so in this story there's a
very rich dwarf King named hymar now he
had three sons who could shape shift for
reasons cuz people can shape shift I
guess now the Norse god Loki he actually
accidentally killed one of the sons
whose name was otter uh because he was
shape-shifted into an
otter and Loki wanted the Pelt yeah okay
yeah yeah so he killed him not knowing
that it was a shapeshifting person right
so he felt kind of
bad so he tells hymar the dad tell you
what I have this treasure
that I stole from this other dwarf named
andari now one of the things that he
gave him out of the treasure was a gold
ring and it was a cursed ring everybody
that had it um it would like make you
miserable and like cause people to die
around you and [__] like that which like
I said very very zero token this is
where he got the idea the One Ring yeah
the one ring my precious yeah now and
again this is going to even start
sounding more like it in a second
because Kar the dad he gets the ring and
he started becoming completely obsessed
with it um and he doesn't want his sons
to know about it he's my preing it right
yeah yeah so it was that um but they
also cuz the Ring's kind of magical I
guess so they're just kind of like oh
[__] I want that [__] too um so faer one
of the sons murders his dad to get the
ring and then transforms himself cuz he
can shape shift into into a dragon to
watch over it like smog like smog yeah
yeah that's like I said that's where Jr
Tolen got the idea from now even though
smog didn't have the ring no but he had
like a treasure had bunch of yeah so
like I said that's this is kind of like
a similar kind of story okay now faer
eventually gets killed by his brother's
well I guess it's like his nephew kind
of or look like his brother's stepson I
guess now the brother's stepson is
supposed to go kill the dragon and steal
the treasure and the
ring but the stepson also gets sucked in
by the whole ring thing and ends up
killing the stepdad and like the curse
continues you know what I mean like the
ring so like I said this is very very
similar to the like the one ring story
like with Gollum and everything like
that from Lord of the Rings because you
know JRR tolken was really into
mythology and this is he read story yeah
this he read the story cuz it's kind of
famous um and this is kind of slightly
there's a lot of Norse stuff in to Wy
based it on yeah dwares dwarves making
magical weapons and liking gold and
that's all that's all Norse yeah um
other dragons from Norse mythology
include uh nidhog I guess is how you
pronounce that um and he's a dragon that
supposedly lives under the tree of life
igdrasil
um And he supposedly eats like bad
people like murderers and stuff and he's
he's kind of like a ambiguous figure
he's not like a bad guy or a good guy
but he's just like he eats bad people
but he also is supposedly like brings
balance to the universe you know what I
mean like he's like so it's kind of like
the tree of life is good and then
there's like this Dragon underneath it's
like kind of like the bad thing but it's
sort of like ambiguous you know what I
mean it's like it's it's a balance like
the light and dark side of the force or
whatever it's kind of like
that um there's also
another uh dragon who's called oh my God
this the
pronunciation yorman Gander yman Gander
yeah um he's also called the dragon of
Ragnarok or the great
beast and he's supposedly yeah the
apocalypse right he's supposedly one of
the like one of the sons of Loki and one
of his wives so and again like a big
giant snake like a big dragon um and one
of the prophecies about him was that he
was like during Ragnarok he was supposed
to kill
Thor um so this is the same serpent that
was so big that he could encircle the
Earth midgard serpent so the midgard
serpent ENT is what they're talking
about um
now like interestingly I kind of feel
like like a lot of the Viking um
mythology the Norse
mythology um their dragons were a lot
more like big
snakes yeah they didn't really look as
much like and I kind of feel like a lot
of and particularly the Vikings who were
really
seafaring um a lot of seafaring cultures
had
stories about big giant sea monsters and
I'm sure that that probably came from
like [__] they saw and like
exaggerations of stuff they saw and also
because seaf fairing was very um
treacherous
so any any anything that you indulge in
that is that treacherous is going to you
know kind of have these big like [__]
stories and legends and [__] like that
around it so although a lot of the Norse
weren't weren't Vikings of course only
the men were and the young ones and it
was only at certain times when they got
desperate when
the when the Farms weren't doing that
well I've I've read that a lot of the
Norse were peaceful stayed home a lot of
times the Vikings I would probably think
that they would go Viking you
know I'd always heard that well in some
sources that I remember reading this
it's old though now because I haven't
really looked at it
recently that the the Vikings were more
like the Norse version of the Pirates
they're kind of equivalent to a pirate
it wasn't really the norm although they
did have a big influence on the
culture yeah and I they also had Warrior
Cults that took a lot of J Drugs Bez
arkers but Bez arkers would go into the
bezark that was basically like a viking
an elite
Viking they would go Viking they' go
berserk too yeah that was part of the
thing you know so I don't
know it's hard to tell what's historical
and what's Legend with a lot of
that and I think that's kind of true up
a lot of cultures you
know but because the the Norse religion
also had a big Christian and Roman
influence on it yeah uh people think
that it's it's spro it's sprung up out
of
nowhere no they nothing does nothing
does uh the Norse kind of colonized that
area over time the the north land they
didn't their ancestors didn't come from
there um and with them they brought the
Roman alphabet which you know them as
runes it's just a different version of
the Roman alphabet and it was how they
wrote their language but they also had a
lot of magic and religions involved in
it over time they kind of morphed into
Christianity where they were believing
in North myth Mythos and Christ
Christianity at the same time towards
the end part yeah and then eventually
they just kind of got rid of the Norse
parts of
it the descendants of the Vikings didn't
like the old culture they thought it was
too barbaric I
guess you know just the way people are
yeah that happened a lot even in like in
England and [__] the descendants of the
Saxons wanted nothing to do with their
ancestors that they were [__] Savages
that kind of [__] you know
which like you can understand you're
like look I just want to [__] chill
out and like live a normal life I don't
want to like [__] go out and get my
ass stabbed and [__] like that not like
much fun does it but yeah so um so I to
to the actual the Norse word for dragons
in general was Drey which was kind of
like the old English Drake uh same kind
of uh the same route and that was the
same word that they used for like sea
serpents dragons anything like sea
monsters anything like that um they also
use that word to refer to certain types
of ships because some of their ships you
know as most people know had like dragon
heads like carved on them like to
intimidate people and stuff like that so
that's kind of what they called so like
I said dragon's also a very large part
of Viking culture now in case I did not
mention this before which I don't think
I did I thought we brought up Bea wolf a
little
bit but bolf the old English
poem also has a dragon in it because the
whole inciting incident of bolf is a
person taking something from a dragon's
horde CU like I said that was a very
common thing in Western Dragon mythology
was that dragons had treasure hordes and
like guarded treasure hordes I'm not
entirely sure like why that came about
but that's a pretty common um Trope in
Western Dragon mythology was them
guarding
Treasures so somebody goes in there
takes one thing from The Horde the
dragon wakes up and gets mad because
like not like he doesn't have a million
other things he just like oh my God that
was my favorite thing and then he just
goes on a big [__] rampage so Bea
wolf is like okay I'm gonna go fight
this dragon all by myself even though
I'm an old [__] man
um but then there's one of his 12
Warriors who's the youngest guy whose
name is uh wigo and he's like no I'm
going to come with you like to help you
fight this Dragon so when they're
fighting the dragon Bea wolf his sword
breaks like in the fight and he gets
[__] up like he doesn't get killed but
he gets like you know he he gets a bad
enough wound that he's like yeah I'm
going to die from this [__] [__] but
wigo comes and helps him kill the dragon
uh bolf dies spoiler alert and he tells
wigo he's like okay well all those other
[__] that didn't come with me
to help kill the dragon they're not
going to get this [__] treasure so
you go bury that somewhere they don't
know where that is you know what I mean
uh cuz they didn't come help me out so
he was a little like [__] in that
regard so as I mentioned earlier what we
consider the
modern image of the Dragon like the one
that flies around with the wings and
breathes fire and [__] like that that's
mainly from like the high Middle
Ages and that image comes from like a
combination of you know the Greco Roman
stories um the near East dragons like
Mesopotamia and stuff like that the
dragons they had there that and the
biblical kind of stories about the
dragons and also kind of like folktales
you know about dragons from that era so
high high Middle Ages the dominant Force
cultural Force artistic force in that
era would have been France too yeah so
probably a lot of the imagery of dragons
as we would know them you know Europeans
white
people probably French a lot of that
imagery well French English wel they're
using it yeah the French are probably
synthesizing it because a lot of stuff
about Arthur of course is [__] French
you know because you had English living
in France yeah yeah you know Britney
it's why it's called that the Normans
and all
that so probably a lot of that winged
serpent winged lizard concept might be
French
possibly where probably the art came
although like I said I'll get into it in
a little I bet you if you look at
[__] gargoyles and stuff you're going
to find that and those yeah well the
interesting thing about and I'm not
really sure how much I believe this but
there is kind of like a a backstory
about gargoyles yeah um about like where
they came from that it was just kind of
like oh there was this dragon that was
called gargo or something like that and
it's like there was like this story
about it and it's like now that we've
defeated it we're going to put it on all
the [__] Cathedrals yeah like I said
I think that was kind of a backstory
like I think they they did that later
but I'm not really entirely sure why
they put those on there but yeah that
that was another thing that like people
went into but I kind I had that in my
notes but I was like well I don't know
how relevant that is so I kind of left
it out um but yeah so so there was a lot
of so I feel like the Heyday of like the
dragon
mythology was kind of
between the 11th and the 13th
centuries so here's a very like kind of
a famous story about the Devol a dragon
and this happened in the 12th century
this was uh written up by Jeffrey of
Monmouth who was a monk a Welsh monk
actually and he wrote a story um he
wrote a book that had a story about
Merlin uh you know yeah that Merlin
yeah so apparently when Merlin was a
kid he sees uh vortigern who was a
warlord and he was trying to build like
this castle like a tower on the
Mountain like or a hill mount
Snowden um to try and like keep his ass
safe from the Anglo-Saxons right but
every time he tried to build this Tower
it kept getting like [__] sucked into
the Earth for some
reason Merlin who was you know um kind
of magical and everything he says well
you know why that's happening is that
underneath this hill there's like a pool
or like a a body of water and there's
two dragons sleeping in it so you might
want to sort that
out so vortigern calls the medieval
equivalent of you know the plumber or
whatever the [__] and he comes and they
drain the pool like underneath this hill
and indeed they do find two dragons in
there sleeping there's a red one and a
white one now as soon as they drain all
the water out the two dragons start
fighting with each other cuz I guess the
water was the only thing keeping them
from fighting they they were sleeping
before and they're like now we're awake
we're bad pow and they start
fighting Merlin says well the white
dragon is going to beat the red one um
which most people would recognize as uh
symbolizing England the white dragon uh
you know triumphing over Wales the red
dragon um and that is indeed what
happens in the story so this was a very
popular story if you don't know
uh the Welsh flag has a red dragon on it
and um that's kind of like their mascot
their version of the E is the red dragon
yeah their flag is like actually really
cool it's like it's a it's green on the
bottom and white on the top and then
it's like a big red dragon in the front
and that's like a big thing in Wales
like that red dragon thing but yeah so
that's and that might be why because of
this story it's the red dragon versus
the white dragon it's like Wales versus
England is kind of uh what that story
means so yeah so this was like a hugely
popular story uh throughout the 15th
century now as I mentioned earlier um
probably the
first image of what we would recognize
as like the modern dragon with like the
wings and the fire breathing and
everything like that comes from a
painting or like an illustration rather
from like a medieval manuscript from
around
1260 now in this illustration the dragon
has a bunch of wings and it has like a
like a big long tail and everything like
that but it kind of looks like what you
would recognize like as a modern dragon
and that's pretty much the the first
time that you see all of the features
that you'd recognize as a modern dragon
in a picture so from
1260 um now in this time
period as in Asia dragons are generally
associated
with water um as living in rivers or
Seas or something like that or as living
in caves or underground that's another
thing um that comes about in the Middle
Ages they're also generally considered
um negatively they're seen as um greedy
they generally just want to eat maidens
that's a big thing um and because of
Christianity because the INF influence
of Christianity they're usually
associated with uh Satan so it's always
generally always considered a Bad Thing
uh there's actually a story from the
13th century which is very famous um and
this story was originally written in
Latin but you know kind of spread
outward after that um and this is the
story of St Margaret of Antioch who was
a martyr uh she was a virgin and she got
tortured for being a Christian
and kind of thrown back into her jail
cell or whatever and then she somehow
comes across this big ass dragon in some
versions of the story she just like
makes a cross at him like you would at a
vampire and the dragon
disappears however in the better
versions of the story she actually gets
eaten by the dragon and then she makes a
sign of the cross inside the dragon's
stomach and then pops out like okay you
know what I mean which is much better
obviously cuz it's like it's not cool to
just be like oh go away Dragon he's just
like oh no poof but it's like if you
actually get eaten by the dragon and
then you're making the sign of the crop
like inside the [__] that's much more
badass so yeah I like that version of
the story better where she just like
pops out and she's like yeah I'm fine so
um also in case you thought that I
wasn't going to mention this probably
the most famous easily the most famous
story in uh England is St George
obviously he's the patron saint of
England and every single image you see
of St George he's killing a dragon
because that's the most famous story
about him um earliest version of the
story that they know of comes from the
6th
Century um and the kind of most famous
version of the story so there's this
dragon and it keeps [__] up there's
this town in Libya called silene I think
is how you pronounce it so the dragon
keeps coming there and eating all their
sheep so they're not happy about that so
it eats the sheep and then it eats a
Shepherd which they're really not happy
about and so then they're like dude okay
can you not eat the people so they start
putting two sheep a day out for the
dragon to eat it's like please do not
eat the people just have these thank you
it it's that
um but eventually the dragon cuz it's a
dragon eats all of the sheep and at this
point they're like okay well now we have
to start feeding it the people so they
start like doing a lottery where you
know we're going to put your person out
like every day like sorry about that you
know what I mean so they start doing
that now one day nobody moves of course
I would have [__] I'm out of here
yeah I I I don't really like like the
the town where he's like you might get
eaten by a dragon I I don't really like
that idea thank you very much Jeffy art
yeah St St Margaret was the xenomorph of
dragons yeah she just like did that [__]
from inside the stomach I just I love
that but so yeah so they do the lottery
now one day in the lottery the King's
Daughter the princess comes up in the
lottery and the King's like oh no she's
the princess she's special we can't like
not like these Hoy pooy you know what I
mean we can't have that but you know
everybody in the town is like nah man
she's the same as the rest of us she
came up in the lottery so sorry put the
[__] wedding dress on her and put her
out there like to get eaten by the
dragon you know what I mean so she gets
put out there to get eaten by a dragon
in a wedding dress in the wedding dress
yeah cuz that's what you had to do
apparently I don't know if they did that
to the boys or what but they put them in
the wedding clothes trying to make her
ass look pretty as possible all our
wedding like the dragon doesn't care
yeah maybe he likes his foodal story man
this how this is they thinking they're
trying to get the audience to go damn
they're going to feed her that pretty
ass a rich girl going to put her out
there going to put the wedding dress on
her and everything you know she was in a
cocktail dress right yeah well that's
well see that's what I mean they know
what they're doing King Kong is like
like a modern version of that yeah so so
she's out there in the wedding dress
chain of the rock or whatever like
waiting for the dragon to come eat her
so it so happens that St George mosey's
on by I don't know what he was doing
prior to this farting around somewhere
so he comes out by and he's like oh no
we can't have this happen like all of
the other people in the village have
been eaten and he didn't come by and
help anybody but now that it's the
princess o now I'm going to take notice
you know what I mean so he comes by and
he's just like okay we can't have this
so he stabs the dragon with his little
Lance or whatever and then he makes a
sign of the cross at it because that was
something that was supposedly going to
work and then he takes the princess's
girdle off and I was
like how'd you get that off off from
under the wedding dress like what's
going on here wedding dress might not be
built the way you're imagined maybe not
I'm kind of thinking girle is something
that goes underneath so I'm like did you
did she get naked or an external corset
okay maybe we but like I said generally
oh thank you so much Bryce thank youy
loving this episode I think every
everyone uh mythologize reptiles or fish
it seems to be everywhere yeah right
some think Queen Elizabeth was a lizard
man yeah we should probably do a show
about that one of these days too like
the whole lizard man thing yeah but uh
cuz that's kind of fascinating although
that would probably just make me mad but
you know what I mean so yeah so I so I
got kind of hung up on this whole like
princess girdle detail so he takes her
girdle off somehow and wraps it around
the dragon's neck which somehow like
subdues it because she's a virgin I
guess I don't really know wa she puts a
girdle around its neck he put the girdle
around it's night okay well he stabed it
with a lance too but he didn't kill it
yeah so then it's like it chills it out
yeah it thought that [__] was sexy he's
like oh oh hell yeah all right okay I
don't I don't want to eat her anymore
came from around her yeah it's just hot
it's yeah so that's yeah that's that
might be what they're talking about
that's kind of what I'm thinking it's
like yeah you said put the garer on it
put saying I put a garer bell panties on
there yeah put the panties on it that's
probably that's that's probably exactly
what it talks we're saying girdle but
it's panties maybe put the panties over
just like that thing was like oh hell
yeah yeah yeah it starts sing it it
starts sing its ass off his weakness it
really does it's his weakness so so
basically what you're saying is
that okay this is the combination of
male and female energy that's what's
destroying the Dragon yeah you got this
Brave dude with a weapon and then a
woman's sexuality is helping bringing
bring bringing it chilling it out
chilling it out so you make it weak yeah
yeah so so it doesn't kill it like he I
don't know where he stabbed it with the
Lance yeah but he's got like the the
girdle or the panties if you prefer and
so probably they wanted to say panties
but they couldn't but they're like oh
that's they censor that that's yeah that
was I thinking so St George then brings
the Dragon
who is now just like a little puppy on a
leash I guess yeah and they bring him
back into the town now here's where it
gets kind of shitty because St George
says you know I could kill this Dragon
for you if all you [__] convert
to Christianity okay like otherwise what
he's just going to like let it keep in
that seems like blackmail just going to
SEC no he in the thinking of the time
he's doing what's best for them he's
saving your Souls I'm going to save your
souls
yeah you accept if you accept Christ as
your savior you will go to heaven and
I'm saving your souls and as a reward
I'll kill it's all for you yeah it's all
for you and I'll kill the dragon yes I'm
he's hero as a [__] like I said
sounds like a little like black yeah and
they've they've comi they combined the
sacred feminine and the [__]
masculine together to get this done I I
see what they did yeah I mean I see it
too but like I said in modern parlons it
seems a little bit like blackmail yeah
it's like hey if you don't convert to
Christianity then I'm just going to let
I'm just going to let [__] eat you well
you're Sinners you deserve what's going
to [__] happen we're all going to die
anyway you're going to die now and
you're going to go to hell but if you
[__] convert I'll save you God will
save you I'll help God cuz like look I
got him right here like least like a
little puppy dog yeah and then I could
kill him yeah and only a man and woman
can do this together yeah that's what
what happen cuz there's chivalry going
on here so of course that's what so
everyone's like oh yes okay we'll all
convert to Christianity please kill the
dragon so whatever so he did kill the
dragon with his sword or whatever so
like I said that's St George now in some
versions of the story he actually
married the princess of course because
that's how fairy tales end um but in
some of them he just kept on wandering
like [__] zichi like [__] it I got or
mad or whoever slay I got other women I
got other [__] to do I just women to
save yeah that's what I mean I got other
women to save from getting eaten by
dragons and you know what I mean I I
can't tie myself that way you can use
the that way you can use the character
in other stories sure like I said it's
like a do an expanded universe like I
said it's like zigi or you know the man
with we only have some of these stories
probably a lot of them
lost there's probably probably a lot of
sequels to it like in like a movies but
the sequels weren't as good so they had
stay they didn't stay yeah probably not
I mean cuz obviously that was like
that's probably the most famous story
well that's the most famous story about
dragons in England for sure yeah because
like I said St George is like their
patron saint you know what I mean and
you see if you go to the UK there's like
imagery of St George slaying the Dragon
like everywhere all over the place um so
yeah and there's a lot of dragons in
heraldry as well and that also comes
from the Middle Ages and I find I kind
of feel like I think we kind of brought
this up before but in the Middle Ages I
kind of feel like that was when the
distinction came about between a dragon
which has four legs and a wyvern which
has two legs yeah before you go too too
deep off into this explain to them what
heraldry is in case people from other
countries don't know what that is well I
would have thought that everybody knew
what that was but it's just kind of well
I mean you just have you have like a
family crest or like a shield and it has
like all of these different things on it
that are symbolic of your family family
line and your station and and and yeah
it was most people were illiterate in
this era a lot of the nobles were
illiterate but you could tell a person's
status what their family name is if you
cuz there are so associated with colors
and patterns and symbols like a a
rampant lion or a
rampant uh
[__] uh a dragon or head of or or or
a or a helmet painted on the shield
different kind of flowers like all yeah
there was all different kind of like
symbolism and that symbol if you saw it
usually it's on a shield or on a Crest
above a door or you know outside
somebody's tent you would know what that
guy's name is and how powerful he is
what family he's from that kind of stuff
yeah cuz everything meant something and
everything meant something it was
symbolism yeah it was like emojis for
like emojis for the uh for the
illiterate and most people were
illiterate but it was very beautiful art
if you ever see anything from like you
know uh any of these medieval night axe
that you can see and they have these
[__] pretty symbols on the Shields
and flags and [__] that's heraldry yeah
emojis Erica said those stories of St
George and such are metaphors for like
getting rid of the pagans same with St
Patrick chasing away all the snakes in
Ireland yeah I agree uh and then she
says my family could have arms on my
mom's side is a unicorn yeah some of
them did have unicorns on real British
so I thought that was like pretty cool
there's also things called Clan tartans
which is a plaid pattern yeah that's a
Scottish thing it's a Scottish thing I
think the Irish and the Welsh have too
though yeah I don't know it's like not
so much the Welsh but yeah the SC that's
more of a SC it was part of your Garb
you know your kilt and your jacket and
and U it it said it basically tells you
what your last name was depending on the
pattern
yeah John Robertson said heraldry is
fascinating the Robertson family of
Scotland has a red shield with three
silver wolf heads on it and a hand
holding the Scottish crown on the helm
on the top yeah yeah so it's like it's
pretty weird like my maiden name which
was Mitchell um my dad looked up one
time like the herald D because I guess
that's an Irish name I can't even
remember what the shield looked like now
what the [__] was on that I'd have to
look it up again I don't remember but he
did like kind of show it to me like one
time like with all the symbolism on it
but it's like pretty interesting maybe
we should do a show on that yeah that
might be
interesting so let's talk a little bit
about we're going to talk about like
North and South American uh dragons and
then we're going to talk about maybe
where where all of these things came
from came from you know what I mean so I
knew this was going to be a long show
but I mean it's not too bad we're just
at three hours and like I said I really
did cut it down from how long it was
before I went through like earlier today
and I'm just like I got to take that out
I got to take that out I had to take so
much stuff out but you know what I mean
so yeah so let's talk about a little bit
about and I feel like a lot of people
don't really ass
associate Native American or
Mesoamerican mythology with Dragons but
a lot of the um creatures that they
describe are very dragon likee and I
think that you would recognize them as
dragons like you know what I mean
so they're just not like as well known I
guess so uh one of the most famous ones
I guess is the
PIAA I'm guessing that that's how you
pronounce it now this has been depicted
on several um like kind of limestone
like rock walls and stuff like that
there's like drawings of it um probably
the most famous one is in Illinois in
Madison County and this is kind of
like it has like kind of bird
wings but it then it has like kind of
claws like bird or bat kind of Claws and
then it has gold scales on its body like
reptilian and then on its head it has
like horns like an elk and it has like a
big long spiky tail so it doesn't really
look
like maybe like a classical Dragon but
if you showed it to somebody they'd
probably say hey that kind of looks like
a dragon kind of thing because you know
it's like I said it's an amalgamation of
like a bunch of different animals
there's also
another um kind of dragon like thing
from uh right around the Great Lakes
region and kind of looks like it has
like a cat sort of body but it has like
scales on it and then it has like a
reptile type of tail and then it has
like bullhorns you know what I mean so
again kind of this is um from like
Native American this is Native American
we're going uh North and South American
at this point okay so the combined
animals that they've seen before yeah
yeah yeah so like I said which is what
the European and Asian conception of the
Dragon it was a
compilation of animals yeah it's snake
like but there's other stuff is there
North American Indians this is yeah this
one they're talking about mountain lions
and probably bison you know yeah the
horn I have to see the horns it's not
deer antlers it's curve horns like on a
like on a bull or kind of yeah well they
didn't have Bulls so uh that native to
there what they're talking about is a
bison you know both but a lot of but
they do have like but they have wings on
them like bird wings and then they have
like claws like bird claws oh yeah
they've seen they they saw Condor and
that's what I mean eag so it's the same
conception I kind of feel like it's the
same idea yeah I don't think they saw
Condors up here Eagles and North
American Indians also
have serpent
like creatures um you have one L like I
said I'm sure the pronunciation of this
is going to be like really really bad
but there's one called the
Kena kipa kipa that sounds like Indian
word um was a big land snake and that it
would grow by shedding its skin off and
then it would go and become like a sea
serpent yeah so there was one of those
there was one from actually seol
mythology which is from from here from
Florida and this pronunciate there are
no vowels in this so I'm going to be
like have a hard time
um suck with
Vana I don't know there's lots of v's
and W's in there I'm not sure if I
pronounce that well the seol were from
here yeah a lot of them accepted
American citizenship during the trail of
tear area other ones got moved up I
think above Texas if I remember
correctly not um so that could have been
up there too not just Florida yeah if
they brought that myth with him maybe
yeah but this one was a big sea serpent
with horns and interestingly the horns
of it were considered by the seol to be
an
aphrodesiac so they were always like
trying to catch it you know what I mean
like to get the horn so they could like
grind it up and and eat it I guess and
then there was another one that actually
sounds a lot like a European Dragon even
though stories of this come from before
the Europeans arrived here and this is
called
the
gend
not really sure if I'm pronouncing that
correctly um this one is from senica
mythology and also like Asian dragons
lived in lakes and rivers and it also
flew and breathed fire which is kind of
interesting because a lot of um sounds
like yeah sounds like a
dragon now meso America um was I think
more people people know about that like
have a lot of kind of serpent like
dragonik myths that are kind of similar
um the main difference between
Mesoamerican dragon-like creatures and
European and Asian ones is the
Mesoamerican ones tend to have
feathers and that might be because of
all the tropical birds I'm thinking um
you know in the Mesoamerican a from the
jungles and stuff like that like maybe
that's why because they saw like a lot
of tropical birds that had these really
colorful feathers and so they added that
to their mythology could be Poss could
be that they saw snakes too yeah which
meant that they probably were killing
and eating snakes part of that process
might invol might involve descaling that
snake same way you you descale a fish
they may have noticed the scales and
feathers are the basically the same
thing yeah they are so they well they
they are they are the same thing they're
made of the same material so it's just a
different um you're Envision
configuration if you're going to
Envision a badass snake that's something
that was from the heavens and respect
from the gods I got PE again like like
like a snake a Godlike superhuman
[__] snake a superior Supreme Being
type
snake you might want to imagine that
snake having
feathers so because it can
fly well that
so what what the meso Americans are
talking about something kind of like a
Chinese dragon because that flew too and
they didn't have wings they flew through
flew by spiritual power they levitated
so that could be what what they're
talking about in mezal
America associated with the sun
Celestial stuff that's probably what
they're talking
about because
uh people uh people like the uh the meso
Americans and of course the North
Americans they had cities meso America
had cities at this time the time the
Cortez showed up the 1400s their cities
were bigger than anything in
Europe but they didn't have the wheel
they didn't really have paved roads they
farmed all throughout the countryside
then they were so they were real well
attuned to nature and
animals they saw these animals all the
time now if you're in the City you know
you're probably the only animals you're
going to see or maybe some expensive pet
or something that's being sold as a as
food in the market but it's totally
plausible
that if you're trying to create a
religious story about Supreme Beings who
are
serpents that come from the
heavens the scales being feathers would
be a good explanation of how they
fly yeah you know and like I said maybe
they didn't I mean now we know that
scales and feathers are essentially the
same thing I'm sure they looked at it
and go that's basically the same thing
yeah I mean it looks similar if you look
at it close birds fly because they have
feathers yeah they have
wings if you have a flying serpent from
the heavens it's got feathers on it
that's what makes it fly yeah I mean
that makes what they're that makes sense
that's what they're doing well like I
said I mean feathers they're not talking
about the intricacies of [__]
aerodynamics if a [__] got feathers on
it it's going to fly that's the same
thing as a Chinese dragon yeah cuz
feathers are modified scales yeah is is
all they are yeah so your snakes
feathers your snake scales are feathers
which and maybe just instinctively they
kind of understood that they kind of
understood it but that explains why it
flies how it's in the heavens yeah
that's what they're talking about yeah
the interesting thing about a lot of the
Central and South American quote unquote
dragons is that a lot of them much like
the Asian ones they were generally
either I don't want to say like
necessarily good guys but they weren't
evil um they were
either ambiguous figures in that they
could be good or bad just like nature
could
be um or they were helpful you know what
I mean or they were you know gods of
something yeah they weren't really seen
negatively as they were in Europe yeah
there their snakes had feather they're
they're flying serpents had feathers on
they did yeah and they were like usually
like multicolored they had multicolored
scales multicolored feathers I mean
they're really cool looking I thought if
the person trying to tell this story
living in the United States in the 1960s
it's not going to have scales on it's
not going to have feathers on it it's
going to have rockets on it all right
that makes it Fly that's a makes it fly
into outer space the heavens that's what
they're doing yeah humans are ingenious
man that was how they explained
we come up with some good [__] sometimes
like I I really love the creativity of
like all the stories like before they
knew what was going on really they're
like well we just have to have a story
to like explain it so they would just
they came up with like some really cool
[__] I mean you know I mean that's
really cool but yeah so probably the
most famous of the Central South
American dragon likee creatures were as
we mentioned earlier K quad um who was
basically a flying snake I mean he
didn't have any legs really but he had
wings though and he had scales and
feathers and wings yeah and wings so
he's the dragon and he was a shape
shifter okay he could transform into a
person into into a man Dron which like I
said that's there's there's some
precedent for that like in European in
ancient Greek and stuff like that in um
stories like some dragons or some people
could transform into dragons and vice
versa and in Norse mythology was a
dragon what it well I mean he looks kind
of like a dragon pretty
much um and the thing about it was that
he not only could transform into a
person but he could also transform into
the sun yeah and when there was a solar
eclipse so that's why they said it's
that was supposedly the Earth serpent
swallowing ketzel koad yeah like it was
kind of like a thing like that I I
didn't know the story that equated KET
quad with the Sun I didn't real I
thought the son was a separate entity
but he can become the son if he needs to
if he wants to but I don't think he's
the son all the time but he can become
the son if he wants to gotcha he was
also uh kle quad also called kulon just
like your drink yeah um he was the only
as far as I know the only God from this
Pantheon that did not request human
sacrifices like he didn't want them he
need him yeah I guess he was too cool I
guess um and there are actually stories
in the in the um mythology about ketok
Kad fighting with some of the other gods
about that yeah seeing it was not cool
like that's not cool but like the other
got are like no it absolutely is cool we
we want all the human
hearts almost sounds kind of like a el
die or a God Almighty figure like a
father of God the father of the Gods
yeah where he's strong but he's kind of
on your side yeah so that and you know
um El Shai at first Ed the first born
you know you which is kind of a dick
move yeah early Jews sacrificed the
first born it's been proven because they
found all the [__] clay pots with the
sacrificed babies in
it now man you got to believe some [__]
real hard to be doing that yeah I think
they were doing they may have been doing
that when they when they were also
calling I don't believe anything
that when they were calling El Shai
Yahweh after the Moses period we we they
may have been doing in that too but all
the all the all the [__] yahweh's
Brothers you know like
Molech and Bale they all demanded
sacrifice too child
sacrifice like they're Gods what the
[__] they need that [__] for they just
want to like see if you'll do it it was
to it was to whoever was in charge of
those
societies wanted to make sure loyalty
was absolute I would think yeah that's
what it's about because that's you'll
give up your first born I wouldn't want
to worship any God that asked me to do
that [__] no well he demanded the first
born of Egypt too remember yeah [__]
n stories he made he boom he made that
[__] happen basically he was saying
these Egyptians are in [__] debt you
haven't given me the firstborn but get
you yield to me and he's [__]
whipping Egypt like a Whipping Boy in in
the [__] during the plague story yeah
I'm going to S all [__] Locas and the
I'm going to take you first form you
River turn into blood all right that's
that's what he's doing the boils and all
of that yeah so that's what they're
doing so it could be k a kado was kind
of like the kind of
like kind of like the uh the
Mesoamerican version of yve Yahweh after
the sacrifice
period and that story is told in the Old
Testament as staying the hand of Isaac
yeah yeah where the angel comes down
stops Isaac no don't no don't do it so
that's story is kind of commemorating
the god no or El Shai and Yahweh no
longer require sacrifice right so that's
what we're talking about here yeah I
mean kle Kad seems like he was kind of
like the Creator God right and he was
like God of other things too like he was
um god of the evening star God Of The
Morning Star god of the Winds he was a
firebringer yeah um uh he was supposedly
created the calendar right also so yeah
he was kind of like the top but he was
also kind of like a dragon even though
he could turn into a person a lot of
times the Aztecs the mes Americans and
the may you know we're talking about the
Mayans and the Aztecs the azc were a
type of mind okay um
they they sacrificed humans most of the
time actually not to appease or to
satisfy good Gods it was to appease
demons that were trying to hurt him this
is according
to Catholic monks that were there on
site trying to get them to stop doing it
they were afraid that the the system
would break down the sun wouldn't come
back and that uh evil would take over if
you didn't plate all these [__] evil
demons right you
know
so they eventually got him to stop it by
giving them a a huge Pantheon the saints
that were kind of like their other God
there's a lot of crossover between the
Catholic Pantheon of gods and Saints to
what what the uh the Aztecs and the mind
believed in they had their own
equivalent to say like the Virgin Mary
and their own equivalent to say like you
know some Saint you know that they would
be uh and demons you know they had their
own versions of it said it was real
similar actually the priests said that
yeah that what they believed
is really similar to to what the
Catholics believed in I kind of feel
like left to their own devices most
humans will come up with the same kind
of stor yeah cuz we're all just we're
all very similar like our are very
similar they evolved in a similar way so
I kind of feel like most people even if
raised in isolation will come up with
similar stories yeah the the even the
the old Spanish that were there in the
1500s were reporting back to the Vatican
that these people are not worshiping
devils and demons they're worshiping
good Gods it's just that they're trying
to appease these demons that they're
afraid of right they're trying to buy
them off yeah they understood it yeah
cuz it wasn't that different wasn't that
different right sure Bryce says among my
people every tribe believes they are
protected by a human lizard likee
creature uh they're woried represented
as human fish lizard likee creatures but
they're actually Spirits each one has a
name too okay Aztec and Maya are very
interesting they are and I kind of feel
like a lot of people don't know that
much about them which is kind of a shame
but you know which is saying Bryce is
that I guess it's a mai belief each Mau
is protected kind of by what what
Muslims would call a gin that you have
your own protective Jin other people
call it Genie it's a spiritual creature
made of fire or spiritual energy and it
does its own thing in another dimension
it's never lived as a mortal creature it
lives in another dimension so that's
kind of what you're talking about yeah
protective Spirit be kind of like having
your own J that's how a Muslim might
explain that or yeah and I kind of feel
like that's well people have in various
other um Traditions
have I guess like Guardian Angels
Guardian Angel so it would be a similar
concept that's a similar concept
guardian angel or your own personal gin
or Genie fulfilling wishes protecting
you although a Jin could be deceptive in
in in in Islamic lore they could be evil
they could be good they could be
Christians they could be Muslims Jewish
Jin and be devil worshiping Jin too
they're evil on so you didn't know what
you were going to get
yeah which I like that better because
that well yeah that's what I mean I kind
of like that better because it's sort of
like realistic didn't really know what
they were like it's like even the even
in the spirit world it's like people
might be like [__] you over or they
might be you know what I mean so it's
just like reality the Jin According to
Islamic law the Jin all Al they not only
they have personalities and
individuality and their own religions
they also had had jobs and they had
property some of them tended sheep in
another
dimension they had
flocks look I have to live in another
dimension and have a job [__] that well
they were a parallel creation that God
had made but they're an extradimensional
being living in a slightly other
dimension they could access us though
sometimes I I I have to I have to Asad
or or Muslim like I know how they access
how they access us but they can access
Us in certain
times well now I mean since we're
talking about kle kadle and I think
you've brought this up before but the
fact that Kel kadle who like I said is
usually portrayed as like a winged
serpent like a dragon essentially but
could uh transform into a person yeah
and there was a story that he um sailed
East on a raft which was made of snakes
or whatever and saying he would come
back so when the span when the
Conquistadors came they kind of like
found out about that story yeah and
claimed that they were KET quad returned
um because it's like he was a a white
dude that came back yet well he's in in
a western interpretation would be it's
El Shai or Yahweh he had an only son
that came and taught things to the to
the
Aztecs then he goes off saying will
return one day that's almost the story
of Jesus yeah he was the son of God I'm
leaving I wasn't killed I survived
crucifixion I'll be back so that's yeah
Jesus
so yeah and I'm sure the monks noticed
that oh yeah big time sure they did
so cool cool KH was
Jesus that's that's the Aztec Jesus like
I said that troop yeah reappeared
all over the world yeah it's a very
common Trope so you got Cortez saying
look I'm Jesus returned yeah cuz they
knew about that like cuz they had heard
about that so they're like oh oh my God
we're going to use that [__] and we're
going to say hey I'm the god J I'm K
quad I'm returned right like he was
supposed to come like he's a white guy
you know I mean yeah he was described as
white with a beard mustache and all that
right so when he came ocean on on a
barge or a ship yeah
the the the Aztecs had no concept of a
ship they knew what
little Pontoon type little things were
because they could get into rivers with
them and stuff when they first saw ships
they thought it was a mountain in the in
the ocean surrounded by a moving
Mountain on the ocean surrounded by
white clouds yeah cuz it like those big
Spanish process a ship cuz they never
seen one that b yeah some kind of
floating mountain with clouds on it the
clouds of course being the sales
right but yeah and like I said the
Spanish once they found out about that
cat quaddle thing they're just like oh
my God we're totally like exploiting
that nonsense right there yeah they just
it's funny though they see that ship and
they have no vocabulary for it to well
yeah they'd never seen anything like
that I think they knew what it was when
they saw it but they couldn't I mean
they knew what a boat was obviously but
it's like they never seen never seen
something that [__] big something
that big like so they sales right they
so they could didn't really process like
what that was yeah I think they knew
what it was something in the water with
people on it and there was big sales but
I don't think they had a vocabulary to
describe it when they got back to the
city they came in a mountain that moves
through the
water yeah and the mountain has clouds
around it it's some that's what it is
they're trying to describe something
that they don't have vocabulary for yeah
they didn't couldn't say sales they
didn't have that word yeah they're just
trying to like couch it trying to
describe it right words that they knew
it's like a mountain Mountain that's
moving in the water a big [__] thing
that you can stand on it's moving in the
water see got guys running around on
Deck yeah that's what it's they see
those big mask it's like a mountain
clouds big clouds it's being pushed by
the clouds yeah yeah which I can't
imagine that must have been really weird
like seeing that [__] [__] yeah
here's something that never really
occurred to me until I read this and I
was just like oh yeah I guess so another
thing that would probably be called the
Dragon would be the Haitian concept of
damala because he is a serpent God okay
it's a big ass snake Okay um and you
know he's like a the father deity yeah
like in Voodoo essentially okay and I
that really never occurred to me I'm
like yeah he's he's kind of like the big
he's like like a big snake you know what
I mean almost kind of like the midgar
serpent yeah yeah yeah so that kind of
that kills me I ever thought of but I
was just like of the Gods no no no but
it's just kind of like one that they you
know ask for things and stuff like that
so it's just like that's technically
that's kind of still a dragon and it's
and he's kind of based around like
fertility as well which some dragons are
also got a couple of other ones which uh
you have an Aztec goddess called uh
katle
CU who was she was usually represented
as a human but she had like a skirt that
was made of snakes and she also had two
like dragon or snake heads like in
addition to her human head which was in
the middle so she had but she had two
other like dragon heads on the side so
that was like I said like an Aztec god
that kind of
represented nature in the sense that it
was like beautiful but also cruel you
know what I mean so like I said a lot of
the gods were kind of like represented
that like you know what explained
indifference sure of how followers could
die yeah like without any real tangible
reason yeah well well the gods are kind
of indifferent yeah um Bryce we did he
says he wants to know more about the Jin
we did a show on the Jin we did actually
it was a while back but yeah we did do a
show about that pretty good show I don't
remember a lot about it but yeah we did
a show about that um also there's a
Mayan God called chock that was a dragon
and he is a rain God yeah and this is
probably the closest other than ketok
Kad this is probably the closest
Mesoamerican God that that looks like a
dragon that looks like an East Asian
Dragon yeah um he had like the the
whiskers and the scales and he was also
a rain Brer like the Asian ones were did
we spell the J with a d DG n
probably DJ I N N I think is the there's
a lot of different spellings yeah Bryce
so that that's the spelling we probably
use DG DJ I and and probably you'll find
the show yeah but we did do a show about
that a while back like I said I don't
remember what we talked about on it cuz
it was a long time ago I remember you
dug up a lot of stuff on it we had did
but yeah so so yeah so the Mayans did
actually have a a rain God that looked
very much like an Asian Dragon um and he
usually had like a lightning bolt in one
of his hands or an axe or something like
that and was also associated with
thunderstorms like I said very much like
the Asian dragons so to wrap up why is
it that all of these vastly different
cultures from around the world all have
myths about dragons which are all pretty
similar um you know there's a lot of
possibilities for that could it be that
they all came up with these stories
independently um was there more cultural
exchange between the civilizations than
we previously thought could they all be
talking about a real animal or an
exaggeration of a real animal or
something like that so here are some of
the theories behind why why these very
specific Dragon myths are so
widespread so you got Joseph Campbell
the very famous
mythologist and he's kind of going on
the theories of Carl Young who is maybe
coming to the thing it's like well maybe
dragons are one of those symbols that
are in the collective unconscious that
it's like that symbolize a particular
thing people don't have to be taught
that everybody just comes with that
their innate Hardware type of thing so
he was kind of coming at it from
that uh thing and he's just like well
everybody just every culture is just
going to come up with that with their
own version of that because it's
hardwired yeah what funny is that the
dragon in the in the original
descriptions in all these cultures is a
serpent and humans all primates are
basically born with an in well that's
the next thing I was going to talk about
aversion to snake
I don't have that but some people a lot
especially in the wild though people
that are and even chimpanzees don't like
them so it could
be with
humans the aversion to snakes they
recognize it as a source of power that
that snake must have some kind of power
if it's bigger it's even more powerful
kind of awesome and fearsome so that's a
good that's a good template to put one
of your God ideas on or God
myth on something that you that is
powerful and you kind of have a respect
fear for it yeah kind of a
thing so that that's what I'm saying it
makes sense yeah that was the next thing
everybody has something like a dragon
right but we're talking about a snake
that flies a huge [__] snake that
flies and does [__] like its heads grow
back later on you put Wings on it
because things that fly have wings or
you put feathers on it
yeah and you put feathers on cuz it
flies in China they said [__] that no it
just flies because it's [__] got so
much chi in it just pain with clouds
behind it it doesn't even need Wings
just it levitates yeah so that all makes
s well there was a book that came out
which a lot of people reference it came
out in 2000 and it was called an
instinct for dragons and it was by an
anthropologist named David E
Jones and he said pretty much what you
said he's like well humans and they've
done experiments with various other
primates monkeys Apes stuff like that
and a lot of them have an innate fear
of
snakes and so he's arguing that maybe
the reason that all of these cultures
have dragon mythology and that a lot of
them look like snakes is because of that
is because it's an
evolutionary it's something that's like
you know left over from our primate
ancestors you know because we had to
look out for snakes all the time and the
fact that um a lot of dragon mythology
has also aspects of big cats and Raptors
like birds um which were kind of our
main Predators when we were still in the
trees in the trees and like you know in
the you the predators of our ancestors
we descended from so he argues that it
could be just because we have this
primeval fear of animals that used to be
our predators that we're combining those
in our mythology which I guess some like
makes some kind of sense you know what I
mean you're using the most badass thing
you can think of right and he argues
scared you yeah he argues also that he's
like a lot of dragon mythology like the
dragons usually live somewhere like in
caves or like in the ocean or somewhere
like that's scary place where you're
afraid to go you're afraid to go that's
why you don't see them all the time
right that's how they explain it they're
down underneath they're in the [__]
water in those damn caves you don't want
to go in there yeah better watch out at
the bottom of that
Lake which I mean there could be
something to that yeah it sounds and
that is kind of going back to what
Joseph Campbell was saying earlier is
like maybe this is like dragons are like
a symbol of like what you know it it
maybe that's something like atavistic
where you know this is something from
our ancestors obviously we don't have to
worry about getting eaten by the
anymore um well most of us at least but
because we still have that in our
DNA um then we come up with all of these
stories about these creatures that are
like an amalgamation of like all of our
Predators like in one big thing you said
in the Greek in the Greek story some of
them spit venom yeah well there you go
yeah that's a poisonous snake is what
they're talking about yeah they're
talking about an asp or a Viper some
sort
which yeah and like I said back in the
old days when we were still living in
caves and [__] like that yeah we did
have to worry about getting attacked by
snakes or big cats or whatever so it
could be that we're just making monsters
out of a combination of those things
that's probably what it is which yeah
maybe it is and maybe like I said before
these the Eastern dragons have four
limbs so not only snakes May
salamanders because the Japanese had the
cap but they were scared of it and it
ate children or killed
children yeah that might have got mixed
in there too yeah where it's a serpent
and it's got four arms and legs like a
giant salamander leg of salamander yeah
so cuz like I said every conception of
the Dragon no matter what culture it
comes from is a combination of different
animals yeah it's not just a flying
snake it's always like it's mainly a
snake but then its head looks like
something else like a lion or a horse or
something it looks like Chinese dragon's
got a red man around it well a lot of
lot of uh uh [__] salamanders have
that too the ones that are aquatic their
lungs are basically gills that are on
the outside of their head
yeah I think there's only a couple that
still have that but maybe a long time
ago there were more of them in China so
it's got them not only is this snake got
forearms and legs like a salamander it's
got a man like a salamander the gills of
the salamander yeah but if it's got a
man it's head and his face is almost
kind of like a lion yeah so the guy
that's drawn it has never seen the
creature He's only seen other drawings
of it so maybe heard a description in
poetry like it got man like a line it's
got four arms and legs like a in
salamander and it's long and scaly with
a fork tongue and it spits spits for
fire and it flies and it's as Fierce as
a lion and it's got a man and then you
start drawing what you would know is a
Chinese Oriental Dragon Chinese dragon
yeah that's you know I could see how
that would happen yeah I could see that
would
happen now we've brought this up earlier
but one of the this is always brought up
when you talk about dragons is that it
could be that maybe ancient peoples that
didn't know anything about dinosaurs
came across fossils
and maybe made the myth out of the of
the dragon out of that um and there was
another book that that also came out of
2000 which was called the first fossil
Hunters um written by Adrien Mayer and
she says that maybe some of the Dragon
Stories came about because of ancient
people coming
across um you know Fossil Beds and like
not knowing what those animals were and
she does note that um a lot of places
where there's a lot of dragon lore um
are places where there were a lot of you
know large Fossil Beds found like a a
lot of like large dinosaurs you know
what I mean but um then she's like cuz
and not necessarily dinosaurs either
they're like because they were fossils
of like big mammals like giant giraffes
and [__] like that which probably if you
saw that and didn't know what it was um
might look like a dragon to you yeah if
you just found the net
right and maybe part of the back and the
other bones are gone yeah you go man
that's a big ass what the hell is
that head it might the head might be on
it you go man that's a [__] big ass
serpent yeah because it's like obviously
I don't see any animals that look like
this nowadays so you don't know what
that is she also Notes too that um in
China where there are a lot of Fossil
Beds and there were like a lot of large
um you know fossil animals found like
you know she's like well a lot of times
you know ancient Chinese people like
even modern Chinese people will dig
those up and they call them dragon bones
and they're used in traditional Chinese
medicine right now she does point out
that she's like well I don't think this
accounts for all of the Dragon Stories
obviously because she's like some Dragon
Stories like the ones from the Norse
mythology and stuff like that they don't
really have any fossil beds of any uh
note up there so they might be getting
the stories from somewhere else although
some people have said like I said maybe
they're finding like huge uh you know
whale skeletons or maybe they're seeing
big giant orish or something like that
that's giving them ideas but she's like
you know so this can't account for all
of the stories might stealing things
that have images big serpents on it cuz
they they raid it a lot yeah it could
been that too they might have been
getting stuff from other yeah cultures
and she also argues she's like well and
these also could be exaggerations of
animals that they saw in real life like
heila Monsters or iguanas or crocodiles
or something like that and they were
just like exaggerating stuff that they
saw you know what I mean so it could
have been that too um so it could have
been a combination of those things I
think part of it is also they're
stealing each other's [__] equipment
and Jewelry and swords and yeah you
Shields and some of the European stuff's
going to have dragons on it yeah and
they see that oh yeah we know what that
is yeah as a dragon and you know however
they're being shown a dragon they just
replicate it and it's probably if we
were to see it would probably look like
a snake they'd probably call it a dragon
right a snake with hands a snake with
two feet maybe a snake with wings that
there it is cuz there are some weird
[__] yeah um like salamander type
animals or like snake type animal that
were kind of like halfway in between
snakes and salamanders that have little
feets yeah you know what I mean it's
inspiring they're not big but they're
little but they still have little feets
on them and they might have been like
bigger back then um also there have been
some other arguments that maybe dragons
were just kind of like a personification
of natural phenom phena like lightning
or rainbows or tornadoes or something
like that maybe they were just kind of
describing it in terms of a living
creature but it was you know because it
was like a natural phenomenon they
didn't really understand what was going
on well if you believe in something
that's kind of super powerful and it's
in the sky it can fly yeah has magical
abilities and that's a good way to
describe Thunder yeah must be that thing
it should be noted that a lot a lot of
dragon mythology is based around Thunder
or storms or rain or something like that
and you see lightning you say well that
might be coming out of the mouth of that
yeah he's breathing fire right yeah a uh
a Greek wouldn't say that they would
just say oh that's [__] you know
that's that's Zeus that's Zeus throw
down his lightning bolts yeah like he
does right they had but you know to a
person that doesn't have
Zeus lightning and lightning bolts and
thunder like yeah that's dragons man
they R in the sky yeah they're like I
don't know what they're doing up there
they're just like [__] fighting man
going yeah that's what yeah if if you
don't have Zeus the Lightning
God you maybe think it's like some kind
of like big ass animal up there yeah um
now this might be I kind of think this
is probably closer to what
happened um there's a scholar from
Harvard University named Michael Whittle
and he's actually knows Sanskrit and he
thinks what might have happened
is that the stories of dragons are so
old that they predate like a lot of the
human diaspora okay meaning that meaning
that TM was not the first dragon right
meaning that the stories are so old that
like when all the humans were kind of in
one spot they all had these stories and
then later they all moved out to split
and then they later became like then
they later diverged yeah like you know
when people that went to the east for
whatever reason um you know they're like
oh all our dragons are like friendly and
cool and like we're this way we went
like our dragons are like evil and
terrible and eat maidens and whatnot and
they think that maybe that Divergence
happened
because at least in the modern parlons
and I think this has gone back like a
long time in the East they tend to be
more I guess like in sync with nature
whereas in the west we're kind of more
we want to dominate nature
and they think that maybe why our Dragon
myths are we have to defeat the dragon
and they're just kind of like man n the
dragons are cool you know what I mean
they just like live with the dragon like
they like the dragon I think a lot of it
it's an instinct if you probably took a
bunch of people colonized an area with
them and these people have no no lore
about any dragon no concept of a dragon
you keep them in isolation long enough
anywhere on the planet they probably end
up see a
snake from
that a thousand years later without any
contact around anybody else they'd
probably have have a dragon probably
they would just based upon a fear of
snakes yeah I kind of feel like that's
just something that a lot of humans
maybe innately have something you
automatically just make up and then
that's something that most people will
just make up then each culture would
have their own story around it so they'd
be a little bit different but I will
note like what like what I was saying
before it's like I kind of I kind of hue
to the theory that I think the dragon
stories are so old that they happened
prior to people like spreading out you
know what I mean so when they spread out
then they diverged I don't think they
diverged first you know what I mean so I
think that's probably what happened and
why I think that is because even among
the Asian stories cuz like I said the
Asian stories are generally like dragons
are super cool and they're you know
signs of wisdom and you know they're
awesome and everything like that but
even in the Asian stories there are some
that are just like the European stories
like there's a Japanese story for
example which is about this guy he's
actually a storm god named
susano and he
fights a eight-headed eight- tailed
Dragon named Yamada no
Orochi exactly like the Western stories
of a storm God fighting a dragon that's
like very very similar and it's very
very old so I kind of feel like what
happened was that like I said when all
the humans were kind of all in a similar
spot they all came up they all had these
stories and then once they spread out
later then they diverged what you what
you're describing is the the Graham
Hancock uh uh you know Graham Hancock
yeah that's basically his thesis that
humans
were all kind of one time in a
centralized civilization that may have
been pretty big they all traded and
talked with each other and had similar
stories but aat some kind of catastrophe
happened maybe what they're talking
about with Atlantis some kind of flood
happened and then people spread out
because that original mother
civilization died they were take they
took ideas with them yeah and then like
when they moved farther away like the
stories diers means that if that's where
the dragon came from that's where Dragon
Stories came from that's also where
pyramids came from because they they
descended from a place where that would
make a lot of sense most places have
things like
pyramids that's a
possibility but I think it's probably
50/50 because it's also possible that
things like pyramids are a natural
consequence of being a human being sure
it's Square I'm kind of I'm kind of half
and half on it I'm not really sure
really all the pyramid is is it square
and then you take a square and you try
to make it as big as you can yeah you
don't it's going to get smaller as you
go up building it by hand you don't
necessarily have to have gotten the idea
from somebody else to do that yeah like
you might just come up with that there's
a lot of differences between an Aztec
pyramid and a Greek excuse me and an
Egyptian pyramid a lot of
differences I think what it is is most
people people make something called
zigarette which is a building it's a
it's a rectangular building you make it
as big as you can and you stand on top
of it you know you look cool you do put
decorations T and then somebody goes you
know what [__] that I'm gonna build
another one on top of that
one you know and the other guy says you
know what I'm gonna [__] [__] that
[__] up by putting another one
on top on top of that one and every time
you do it it gets smaller right all
right and eventually somebody says you
know what [__] all that I'm going to
build one that doesn't have any steps to
it it's going to be a smooth [__]
transition it's just going to be wom
like that all right and they're going to
look at that and go how the [__] did you
make
that you can't even stand on thousands
of years from now this is going to blow
their mind yeah so this is you can't
even stand on this [__] and that's what
the Egyptians did and you can see the
older Egyptian Pyramids they kind of
start off as a zigarette they're kind of
janky looking yeah they look [__] up
they're kind of janky looking and they
got that they got that from [__]
Babylon yeah they had those in Babylon
which is now where Iraq is see that's
what kind of like you know how the whole
thing where it's like oh aliens built
pyramids and all that kind of [__]
which I don't I don't believe that no
but the thing about yeah you can look in
Egypt they have other earlier pyramids
that look [__] up they look kind of
[__] up yeah like they like that was
their first draft Yeah you know they
like well that didn't really work out we
can probably do better than that I'm I'm
pretty sure I know how they buildt it
yeah it was just blocks they put out
made one and then they left the slot so
you can drag the blocks onto the next
one and then as they started building it
they left an empty space that would be a
a [__] tunnel yeah and they had a
train track in it and then I've seen
like a like an animation like a of how
they would do it and it makes to sense
then once they got the top stone in
there they said [__] it let's fill up
this elev this [__] train shaft
basically it had a Subway in it yeah
yeah basically a train tunnel yeah but
it was manually operated they use levers
just like [__] what's his name said
like I said they weren't and they use
levers to [__] move move those
[__] bricks that were on wooden slabs
up that train track by using levers a
bunch of guys working and they were all
built to order and they were all built
to go into each place in order because
they practiced it out of little [__]
yeah they probably made little models
they made a model of it yeah they made
all the little [__] they practi red it
putting it together little cubes that
had numbers on them and they were say
okay how do we get it there and they're
playing with it like it's Legos yeah
okay we're going to leave it Hollow in
here how does it keep going then they
[__] okay how many of these now once
it's done they say okay take it apart
and reverse and put a number on each one
of those and we'll send it to the Quarry
to have it made in in the order that we
need it right to to different dimensions
so that means that you're talking about
a construction company yeah it's exactly
what you're talking talking about well
they would have had that yeah and then
they filled it up on the inside and it
and it left it they there was some stuff
in the inside that they were doing is
they were making it like Chambers and
[__] and slabs for walls but they had it
all planned out yeah you have they
practiced it over and over they put it
together like a model yeah yeah they did
[__] in a [__] building and there's
probably nine [__] nine or 10 [__]
Geniuses in there making those little
bricks and practicing putting it
together yeah that's what they're doing
so do you think that the Dragon Stories
do you think that they all came from one
common source like maybe thousands and
thousands and thousands of years ago
before humans really spread out to any
great degree or do you think that it's
something inherent in humans that
they're just going to come up with no
matter what culture they I think it's
inherent they came up with it because
because they saw snakes some people some
people borrowed it yeah they traded they
were trading with them and they got that
idea somebody gave them something this
is a dragon oh I never seen one of those
I'm gonna put that on my sword yeah
that's cool and become yeah that's
pretty neat those are real yeah they're
real yeah I saw one never never saw one
that's probably what they're doing that
one flying around and then and then
everybody's got their own version of the
dragon and it's they're B blended it in
with creatures that they know from their
environment it's the same I think it's
the same thing as a pyramid yeah same
thing you're going to end up with things
like pyramids cuz it's just a square
building then you just take it to the
next level a square building on top of a
square ability and like you said
rectangle a lot of cultures have
pyramids but they're all like a little
bit different they're all made a
different way and dragons are kind of
the same they're all very similar but
they all have their own kind of cultural
spin on it you take a Aztec pyramid and
start pulling it apart there's another
pyramid underneath it and then pull that
one apart there's another pyramid
underneath that one and it's like it's
like a shell after shell after shell
because every time they build one when a
new king would take over he'd have it
faced and rebuilt to be his Temple yeah
you know so they improved him as they
went some of those things that were
there for centuries so it's not blocks
it's Stones I think they're stones and
there's part of the parts of the faing
has sand in it too Stone and sand they
weren't as big but they were they were
built by hand you know people carrying
rocks and sand and then they faced them
they put a face you know they put Stone
on the outside of it carve it put
stories writing glyphs every all there
all of then they changed the staircase
they got steeper and steeper every time
they put a new one on there but anytime
they [__] busted into a Mexican
pyramid there was another pyramid
underneath it yeah so it was done over
time Erica said I think it's inherent
like big foot haha I think it is well
and like man and he's a wild man and
he's big yeah we mentioned that before
that like Bigfoot is kind of another
myth that is very very widespread around
the globe and everybody kind of has
their own like take on it and it may be
that that was like I said I kind of feel
like it's easier to say with like
Bigfoot or Sasquatch type or Yeti type
creatures because that they all seem
pretty similar like I said it's just
like a big hairy dude yeah which doesn't
seem that weird dragon seems a little
bit more specific so maybe it needs a
little bit more explanation but it might
be the same thing it might be the same
manifestation maybe it wasn't until the
early 1900s that European or Western
zoologists who were the leaders in the
world at that time it was wasn't until
the early 1900s that that they that they
actually believed in the gorilla they
were hearing stories of a gorilla but
they going oh yeah he's he's big hairy
man we've heard that story before yeah
we know that one Sasquatch you heard
they didn't believe it until they saw
saw it and they captured him took him to
zoos and [__] they go yeah the big hairy
Wild Man is real this is it they called
a it's a
gorilla
yeah Danny says what if Bigfoot was
prehistoric humans unevolved I've kind
of thought of that before there are no
Bigfoot I really wanted there to be a
Bigfoot but no it's not possible you
have satellites now that can [__]
pick up heat sources but it could be a
racial memory when humans lived
alongside other protohumans that were
bigger than us that were bigger and fer
it could be that so it could just be
like repeated stories over the years
maybe or it could be just a natural
thing you're out by you're out in the
woods by yourself and you're afraid of a
of a bigger guy running into a bigger
guy a bigger furry yeah and he's
stronger than you and he's [__] crazy
he's wild he got all his hair on him so
you know and he'll eat you like the
skunk cap like Tom will do if if you
catch him on the right day that's right
so that's that's all that's what they're
talking about every every culture kind
of has things like that yeah the yeti
and [__] that's what I'm saying the
problem it's kind of similar the problem
with a North American
Bigfoot is that for something like that
to exist there'd have to be a breeding
population of
them which means there'd be a lot of
them you'd see a lot of signs and they'd
walk somebody hit one with a car yeah
they'd get run over you'd see their poop
or something one would die and [__]
you see you find dead ones yeah you're
you're fishing in the lake and [__] a
dead one comes [__] floating down
across the lake you know and he you know
and not the lake EXC me the river and he
died 100 miles away and his body you
know way up into miles so no there's no
big F and um we have the satellite
technology they can see deer and caribon
and rabbits and [__] from space you see
the body heat and I imagine
that some of those satellites are or AI
just looking for certain [__] and it
probably probably has some AI [__]
protocols in there that if anything's
unusual scene to [__] look at it and
record it so you probably pick up a big
foot what the [__] is this dude doing
out in [__] Canada out in the middle
of nowhere nothing like that's been seen
but you could probably find it with used
the satellites today I still want you to
like put on a Sasquatch suit and go like
run around outside like yeah in the
Everglades or something so somebody
would think that it was there some
compell
Sasquatch
stories there are some US Park Rangers
that believe that
exist of all the Cryptids I'd be the
most receptive to a Sasquatch type
creature I still don't think they exist
but I would be the least surprised if
they found one how about that
yeah L Nest monster does not exist no I
don't believe in that at all there's not
enough food in there and there's but if
they found a Sasquatch I'd be like okay
fair enough there's not enough food in
that Lake it's too cold and I'd be
really surprised if they found a lot and
there wouldn't be one there'd be an
entire breeding population of although I
do find it interesting that a lot of
lakes have similar stories about B
they're afraid of the deep cold deep
yeah you know maybe these are people
that making these stories up that have
never been to the ocean from a long time
ago the deepest thing they know of is
that [__] Lake there's got to be
something down at the bottom of that
Lake
dudes are dying they're missing I don't
know what happened to that guy one dude
got swallowed by
something couldn't have been a catfish
but that might have been what it was but
it probably was a catfish I've seen I've
seen some terrifyingly big catfish yeah
so they could easily swallow a person so
I you know I'm just saying I tend to
think that uh now now that Jenny's laid
it out and thought about it it's
something the humans are just going to
come up with yeah it it might be it just
might be something that's inherent in
our DNA in our brain chemistry you're
taking the fear of snakes and you're
magnifying it yeah and it's going to
manifest differently like no matter what
culture you grew up in but it's going to
be kind of similar across the board and
in tribal societies people that are in
touch with the Earth anything that
you're afraid of is powerful because you
you fear power but you respect it too
yeah so you see a snake and you're
scared of it God there got to be a
reason it's powerful imagine one 100
times that size that's they're thinking
yeah they're going yeah and it flies
yeah so then that that that's how it
begins yeah big ass snake flying big ass
flying snake yeah where it comes out of
the water comes out of the ocean comes
out of a lake oh my God comes from a
place where you can't go cave yeah that
kind of stuff like scary places yeah
snake comes out of a cave it's huge
Draco you know yeah that's what they're
talking about D so everybody's gonna
have that Danny says great show and
topic tonight well done on the
presentation Jenny Tom thank you very
much I'm glad we got through all the
information because I was just like I
was worried because I saw I was like oh
my God are we going to be able to get
through all this and we did and we are
like almost at four hours but Erica says
the same thing she thinks it's it's
inherent like a Bigfoot yeah that's what
I said yeah and and and and pyramids
you're going to come up with [__] like
that yeah everybody's going to come up
with their own spin on the same kind of
thing because like I said humans are
inherently like very similar you know
we're all the same species we're not
really that different uh Tammy says ever
seen the movie the man who killed Hitler
and then Bigfoot starring Sam Elliott I
haven't yet but it's on my list I
definitely want to see that because how
can you not want to see a movie called
that that has Sam Elliot in it I ask you
yeah you know what I mean um but yeah
eventually maybe we should review that
this week yeah maybe we'll watch it this
weekend if we we'll watch it this
weekend maybe if I remember maybe I
should write that down because otherwise
I'll forget man who killed Hitler I'll
remember I think it might be on
um I just saw it on one of the streaming
services the other
day so we might be able to watch it all
right so we're at 4
hours and it's 11:20 so I guess we
better like wrap it up cuz I'm getting
kind of sleepy I got two show but I'm
glad that you guys enjoyed the show I
enjoyed the show I had a really good
time like researching all of this
because it seemed oh my God what are you
doing you unplugged me no I didn't yeah
you did no this is my
plug why did it say what it came up on
here though oh yeah I unplugged the
wrong one for a second but I put it back
in oh okay okay so I'm not crazy all
right I thought you said I was making it
up I was like no it came up on here no I
put it back in all right all right so uh
thank you you guys for hanging out with
us this evening talking about dragons
this was a really fun show to do thank
you for all of your super chats and we
will see you guys again I don't know if
I'm going to be able to do a movie
review tomorrow um I have a movie in
mind but I haven't watched it yet so I
don't know if I'm going to be able to
like stream about it tomorrow but if not
then we are going to do our Regular Show
on Friday night our Sidetrack show as we
usually do so hopefully you guys can
join us for that um but you know
hopefully you guys have a good rest of
your night have a good day tomorrow and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good night